Guten Tag, ich würde Ihnen gerne ein Abhörgerät verkaufen. Brauchen wir nicht, wir nehmen dafür unsere ganz normalen Telefone. Mit einem richterlichen Beschluss haben Sie... Einen Beschluss brauchen wir auch nicht, ist ja unser Telefonnetz. Wissen das Ihre Manager? Nein, aber wir wissen alles über sie.
Auch über Journalisten?
Na klar, zwei sind am Sprechen und wir schreiben mit.
Darf ich das auch?
Nein, nur die Telekom. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 179. Mein Name Tim Pritlove und heute geht es mal wieder um Technik. Vor einiger Zeit haben sich ein paar Leute beschwätzt, gibt ja fast überhaupt keine Technik mehr. Ich glaube, in letzter Zeit ist wieder kräftig nachgeholt worden. So soll es auch sein. Denn der Untertitel lautet ja auch hier Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft und womit die Kultur und diese Gesellschaft auch immer sehr wichtig ist, ist mir die Technik nie unwichtig gewesen. Denn letzten Endes, Technik bestimmt unser Leben, unser Modernes und wie ich weiß, erfreut die Technik euch ja auch alle sehr. Ein auch wiederkehrendes Thema hier bei CRE sind Telefone und insbesondere Mobilfunknetze. Da ist schon über die Jahre so einiges zusammengekommen, eben gerade noch mal so ein bisschen durch die Liste durchgegangen, war selber ganz erstaunt. Und der Grund ist, das Thema nimmt auch so recht kein Ende. Einerseits sind natürlich Mobilfunknetze immer noch sehr relevant, mehr denn je, und das geht ja auch immer weiter. Auf der anderen Seite haben sich auch auf der alternativen Forschungsfront einfach so viele neue Erkenntnisse ergeben, dass es immer mal wieder Not tut, darüber zu berichten. Und so soll es auch heute sein. Und um das zu tun, begrüße ich erst mal hier meinen Gast, nämlich Karsten, Karsten Nohl. Ja, schön, dass du es geschafft hast. Du bist ja sicherlich dem einen oder anderen so in den CCC-geneigten Communities durchaus bekannt. Du hast einige Vorträge gemacht auf den letzten Kongressen und beschäftigst dich intensiv mit Technik, konkret viel mit Kryptographie, aber nicht nur. Was ist denn so dein Werdegang eigentlich so gewesen? Wo kommst du nur her? Wann bist du denn in den Computertopf gefallen?
Vor ein paar Jahren während des Studiums massiv eigentlich erst.
Studium von was?
Studium von Elektrotechnik. Nachher technische Informatik, dann eine Promotion in Informatik, also den Computer von der Hardware einmal zur Software aufgearbeitet und dann in der theoretischen Informatik, also ganz am anderen Ende, speziell in der Kryptographie hängen geblieben. Und das mache ich bis heute. Warum? Extrem spannende Puzzle und auch immer mehr und immer angeblich unlösbarere und die Herausforderung ist schon enorm interessant.
Ja, das heißt, du beschäftigst dich mit Kryptographie im Allgemeinen, aber du hast so ein bisschen so auch deinen Steckenpferd gefunden bei den Mobilfunknetzen, habe ich den Eindruck.
Ja, Mobilfunknetze sind für Kryptographen insoweit dankbar, als dass sie genug alte Kryptographie drin haben, die man noch knacken kann. Der Anspruch heutiger Kryptographie ist es für 10, vielleicht 20 Jahre unknackbar zu sein. Das war der Standard vor 20 Jahren eventuell auch und insoweit sind es heute dankbare Ziele für Kryptoanalyse. Alles, was man in der Entstehungszeit unserer Deckt, GSM und so weiter Technologien erdacht hat, hat sich im Grunde seit 20 Jahren nicht geändert und insoweit kann es heute mit der massiv angewachsenen Rechenleistung kombiniert mit ein paar kryptographischen Erkenntnissen mathematischer Art recht leicht geknackt werden.
Ich hatte hier vor langer Zeit Chaosradio Express 56, lief unter dem Titel GSM Hacking, damals mit Steve, den ich getroffen hatte nach seinem Vortrag auf der Diebsack in Wien und damals stand im Prinzip genau das, was du jetzt sagst, auch so im Raum, nämlich dass der A5 Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus, also das, womit bei GSM die Telefonate der Sprachstrom verschlüsselt ist, naja, wackelt. Damals war das so.
Der hat dann ein bisschen länger gewackelt, als alle das vorausgesehen hatten. Steve hat ja damals angekündigt, dass es bald Rainbow Tables geben würde, mit denen sich A5-1 entschlüsseln lässt. Die Rainbow Tables haben dann noch mal drei weitere Jahre gebraucht, um von einer anderen Forschungsgruppe dann errechnet zu werden. Die Jahre sind mittlerweile abgeschlossen. Die Rainbow Tables gibt es also mittlerweile im Internet. Insoweit der in 2007 angekündigte Dammbruch ist jetzt passiert. Und die Fähigkeit, die bisher Geheimdiensten und Regierungen vorbehalten war, ist jetzt frei verfügbar.
Jetzt passiert, wann genau ist das passiert?
Das war der vorletzte Kongress. Also am Ende des Jahres 2009. Eine weitere Version gab es dann im Laufe von 2010. Und das ist jetzt, denke ich, die Finale. Mit ausreichend Hardware-Einsatz, schnellen SSD-Disk und so weiter kommt man auf wenige Sekunden Angriffszeit. Es ist also aus kryptographischer Sicht zumindest das Ende der Fahnenstange. Schneller muss es nicht mehr werden, um klarzumachen, dass es unsicher ist.
In dem GSM-Hacking-Podcast haben wir uns eine Stunde sehr ausführlich mit dieser ganzen Thematik beschäftigt. Ich will das jetzt nicht alles komplett nochmal wiederholen, aber vielleicht ein bisschen zusammenfiegen sollten wir das Thema jetzt schon, damit wir da auch mit davon ausgehen können. Es gibt ja so einiges zu verstehen, insbesondere wie GSM-Netzwerke grundsätzlich funktionieren. Das ist auch nicht nur in der Ausgabe, heute gibt es wieder mal viel zu referenzieren, da muss es auch getan werden, sondern auch in einer zweiten Ausgabe mit CRE120, die ich mit Harald Welte gemacht habe, mit dem du ja auch viel zusammenarbeitest, wo das Thema OpenBSC war, also seine Freie Software zum Nachbilden eines GSM-Netzwerks, was ja auch schon seit mehreren Jahren auf dem Kongress regelmäßig zur Anwendung kommt, auf den CAMPS, das ist sozusagen der, ich glaube der CCC war so ziemlich die erste, die erste Konferenz, die mit ihrem eigenen GSM-Netzwerk daher kam. Nicht zuletzt deshalb, also in den beiden Folgen wurde noch mal ausführlich auf die Gesamtstruktur wie ein GSM-Telefon-Netzwerk funktioniert eingegangen, aber vielleicht soll man trotzdem noch mal kurz um diese Sachen mit dem A5 verstehen zu können, was das für eine Dimension hat, das noch mal soweit aufdecken. Also was muss man wissen, um zu begreifen, was das bedeutet?
Die wichtigen Elemente des GSM-Netzes oder des GSM-Ökosystems, die für Verschlüsselung relevant sind, sind drei, das Telefon selber, die Basisstation, mit der das Telefon aktuell spricht. Das kann grundsätzlich eine Basisstation irgendwo auf der Welt sein, man nimmt seine Telefon ja durchaus auch mit ins Ausland. Und es gibt den sogenannten HLA oder VLA, also verschiedene Computer beim Operator zu Hause.
Also Home Location Register, falls er hieß, das weiß ich gar nicht, dort schön wahrscheinlich. Wenn es faul ist, ist es immer ein Trailer. Visitor, Entschuldigung, Visitor Location Register, also dann, wenn man sozusagen nicht at home ist, sondern eben zu Gast ist.
Das Telefon und das Heim Operator-Netz kennen ein Geheimschlüssel. Das ist natürlich Grundvoraussetzung für jede Art der Kryptographie. Der geheime Schlüssel wird dann nicht an die aktuelle Basisstation rausgegeben. Wie gesagt, es könnte eine ausländische sein und man möchte die Kommunikation mit dem Telefon schon ermöglichen, möchte aber nicht an den Kooperationspartner die geheimsten Schlüssel rausgeben.
Also es existiert nur ein geheimer Schlüssel oder es existieren mehrere geheime Schlüssel?
Zurzeit auf einem Telefon wahrscheinlich zwei, einer für GSM und einer für UMTS.
Aber wir reden über einen einzigen Schlüssel für den gesamten Standard, für alles.
Nein, nein, pro Telefon selbstverständlich. Also jedes Telefon hat seinen eigenen.
Wie nennt man diesen Schlüssel?
Den nennt man KI. Aus diesem Schlüssel wird dann pro Gespräch oder pro Serie von einigen wenigen Gesprächen ein Schlüssel abgeleitet, also ein Session-Key generiert. Und dieser, der zeitlich sehr begrenzt nur Gültigkeit hat, wird dann an die Basisstation weitergeleitet, nachdem die Basisstation bewiesen hat, dass sie zu einem ausländischen GSM-Netz gehört, in dem das Telefon roaming darf. Also keine hohe Beweislatte. Im Grunde kann jeder GSM-Operator für jeden anderen GSM-Operator jederzeit die Verschlüssel zum Telefon anfordern. Und mit diesem Schlüssel, den sich das Telefon genauso ableiten kann, können dann Telefon und Basisstation kommunizieren.
Aber zu welchen Zeiten wird denn dieser Schlüssel überhaupt erzeugt? Ich meine, wenn er irgendwo abgelegt wird, dann muss er ja auch irgendwann mal erzeugt werden.
Na, der wird im Optimalfall vor jedem Gespräch neu erzeugt, aus Performance-Grund wahrscheinlich. Beschränken sich die Operator zur Zeit darauf, ihn nur nach allen drei, vier Gesprächen nochmal neu zu generieren. Aber grundsätzlich wird er vor dem ersten Gespräch generiert. Also wenn ich das erste Mal ein Gespräch führen möchte mit einer Basisstation, die mich bisher nicht gesehen hat, oder in einem Clustern-Basisstation, das mich bisher nicht gesehen hat, generiert dieser Cluster oder fragt einen neuen Schlüssel an von meinem Heimnetz und sagt dem Telefon eine Zufallszahl, um dem Telefon zu helfen, auch diesen Schlüssel zu generieren. Sodass man dann ohne den Schlüssel über die Luft ausgetauscht zu haben, den gleichen Schlüssel auf beiden Seiten kennt. Und genau dieser Schlüssel ist es nun, der in der H5-1-Verschlüsselung verwendet wird. Also grundsätzlich unterstützt GSM verschiedene Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, da gibt es H5-1, 2, 3 und 4 zurzeit spezifiziert. In heutigen Telefonen, in Kombination mit heutigen Netzen, wird aber eigentlich nur noch H5-1 verwendet. Der nicht der schlechteste Algorithmus ist aus dieser Familie, aber mindestens mal der zweitschlechteste. H5-2 ist damals mal spezifiziert worden als der exportfähige Kryptoalgorithmus. Damals Kalter Krieg und so weiter. Das heißt, den findet man eher in alten afrikanischen Netzen. Also außerhalb von Europa, wo dennoch damals schon GSM-Technologie ausgeheult wurde. Allerdings gibt es mittlerweile ein Mandat der GSMA, also der weltweiten Koordinierungsstelle der Handy-Netzbetreiber. Und das Mandat sagt, dass kein neues Telefon mehr A5-2 unterstützen kann. Das führt zu der paradoxen Situation, dass in den Netzen, zum Beispiel in Marokko, ich war gerade in Marokko, in den A5-2 noch die Pleut ist. Moderne Telefone gar nicht mehr verschlüsseln. Also da gehen die Daten komplett unverschlüsselt über die Luftschnittstelle, weil die Schnittmenge der Algorithmen, die das Telefon unterstützt und die die Basisstation unterstützt, neu ist.
Ach so, weil die Basisstationen alle nur A5-2 implementiert haben. Jetzt kommt kein Telefon mehr, was A5-2 kann. Und dann gibt es einfach gar nichts. Das ist ja auch super.
Genau, also das passiert, wenn man bewusst schlechte Technik ausrollt. Das war damals noch mit dem Hintergedanken, man will den Russen nicht helfen, an gute Technik zu kommen.
Aber das hat die wahrscheinlich nicht davon abgehalten, diese Technik heranzukriegen.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass das Russland damals bessere Kryptografen hatte, als die Kryptografen, die A5-1, den in Anführungsstrichen besseren Standard damals generiert haben. Der, wie wir heute wissen, an seinem Potential längst nicht herankommt. Was dann wiederum heute erlaubt, im Rest der Welt, oder zumindest der westlichen Welt, Telefonate zu knacken, die nämlich genau diesen A5-1-Algorithmus einsetzen, um die Luftschnittstelle abzusichern.
Das heißt, es gibt A5-1, A5-2, was ist das denn mit 3 und 4?
Das sind neuere Standards, die grundsätzlich sicherer wären. Zumindest der 3er wird auch von der Mehrzahl der modernen Telefone unterstützt. Allerdings auch hier wieder die Schnittmenge mit den Basisstationen gleich null. Also es gibt noch keine Basisstationen, die A5-3 sprechen.
Keine einzige.
Es wird sicher welche zu kaufen geben, aber die Basisstationen, die deployed sind, man baut ja keine GSM-Netz mehr, sind so alt, dass es zumindest in Deutschland keine gibt. Es mag Länder geben, in denen GSM noch mal modernisiert wird und in denen dann wahrscheinlich im Zuge dessen auch A5-3 deployed wird, aber in Deutschland ist das eigentlich unerreichbar.
Wie viel muss denn da modernisiert werden? Ich meine, ist das nicht nur ein Software-Upgrade?
Würde man denken, aber Basisstationen sind, soweit ich das verstehe, doch etwas hardwarezentrierter, also sprich Algorithmen, wie zum Beispiel die Verschlüsselung laufenden FPGAs ab. Die grundsätzlich auch Software-upgrade-bar sind, nur sind diese Basisstationen natürlich schon so lange out of support, dass es überhaupt niemanden mehr gibt, der die FPGA-Software dafür anpassen könnte. Es bräuchte wahrscheinlich nur mal eine Taskforce bei Nokia, Siemens, Ericsson und UA, um dieses Problem anzugehen, aber so hoch ist der Leidensdruck scheinbar noch nicht, dass ausreichend viele Operator nach diesem Security-Patch gefragt hätten.
Sind das so die primären Ausrüster der GSM-Netze immer noch?
Ja, die drei und dann wahrscheinlich noch Alcatel, Lucent. Aber im Grunde ist es ein Oligopol weniger Firmen, die die komplette GSM-Netze bauen können.
Das hat doch noch keiner darüber nachgedacht, die Herren vielleicht mal zu verpflichten, so was zu machen.
Soweit ich es mitbekomme, fragen wohl vereinzelte Operator. Zögerlich an, was es denn mal kosten würde, wenn man nur die eigenen Basisstationen mal upgradet und man kriegt immer abstruse zwei- und dreistellige Millionenbeträge genannt für dieses eigentlich nur Software-Upgrade.
Verstehe, die wollen sich sozusagen das Problem vom Hals halten.
Ja, oder sich daran gesund verdienen.
Kann man das nicht die Community übernehmen?
Das Crossroad-Movement Richtung selbstbetriebene GSM-Netzwerke gibt es natürlich schon. Jetzt fehlen wahrscheinlich noch die Frequenzzuteilungen, um das in Realität umzusetzen und echte bessere Netze zu machen. Es gibt aber durchaus Firmen, die sich das in ihren Businessplan geschrieben haben. Das OpenBTS-Projekt mag einigen bekannt sein. Das ist ein ähnlicher Ansatz wie Haralds OpenBSC, allerdings nicht auf einer kommerziellen Basisstation, sondern auf USAP. Das mag auch einigen bekannt sein. Ein freiprogrammierbares Softwareradio. Die Firma hinter OpenBTS möchte alte GSM-Netze modernisieren mit Open Source-betriebener Hardware und insgesamtem Upgrade Pass bieten, um in Zukunft diese letzte Meile oder die letzte Kommunikationsstrecke nicht mehr in alter Technik verschlossen zu haben. Also die Idee gibt es durchaus, allerdings sind GSM-Netze natürlich nur in erheblichen Ausbaustufen vorhanden. Man spricht da immer von Millionen-Subscribern auf einmal. Insoweit hat sich noch niemand getraut, in der echten Operator-Welt Richtung freier oder flexiblerer Software zu gehen. Man ist ja im Grunde doch noch hundertprozentig auf seine Hauszulieferer angewiesen. Harald arbeitet ja an verschiedensten Komponenten. Bist du denn mal jemand, der ein komplettes GSM-Netz schlüsselfertig mit freier Software umgesetzt hat?
Ja, der USRP und OpenBTS, das kam auch in dem OpenBSC Podcast natürlich zur Sprache. Gleich noch mal ein anderer Verweis, also die Sendungen mit Harald sind ja immer so unglaublich ergiebig. CAE 87 ging auch mit ihm um Software Defined Radio, wo es genau um diese ganzen USRP-Sachen und Hardware mit Softwarebauern etc. ein Thema war.
Und die Frage nach der Flexibilität von Basisstationen wird auch in Zukunft in Zukunft noch mit einem leicht anderen Security-Blickwinkel gestellt werden. Die Luftverschlüsselung, über die wir jetzt gesprochen haben, betrifft ja primär nur den Endkunden. Insoweit kein großes Inzente für den Operator, der wirklich was zu ändern. Schmerzer für den Operator wird es, wenn man feststellt, dass die Software an sich schlecht geschrieben ist und zum Beispiel zum Absturz gebracht werden kann. Da wäre man natürlich in der gleichen Zwickmühle, dass man plötzlich jetzt Hardware anfassen muss, die niemand mehr supportet. Forschung in die Richtung hat gerade erst angefangen, war aber durchaus schon ergiebig, dass zumindest im Labor die kommerziellen Basisstationen sehr gerne mal abstürzen. Harald arbeitet ja unter anderem seit einiger Zeit an einem Open-Source-Telefon. Und bei dessen Entwicklungen sind wohl so etliche Testbasisstationen abgestürzt. Wenn das mal irgendwann vandalistisch ausgeschlachtet wird und wirklich kritische Infrastruktur böswillig abgeschossen wird in größerem Stil, spätestens dann stecken wir sehr schnell in der Diskussion, wie kann man denn Handybasisstationen auf eine upgradefähigere Hardware hieven, wo man in jedem Patch-Tuesday die aktuellen Bugs schließen kann.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man sich das Internet anschaut und wie es da so läuft, es ist eigentlich vollkommen absurd, dass in den so wichtigen Mobilfunknetzen da bisher noch nichts passiert ist. Ich meine, dass das sich um eine kritische Infrastruktur handelt, würde sicherlich keiner bestreiten. Würde jetzt alle GSM- und vielleicht auch UMTS-Netzwerke morgen einfach mal so nicht mehr da sein. Wäre das jetzt nicht nur unpraktisch, weil man wieder lernen müsste, sich pünktlich zu verabreden. Sondern was weiß ich, was da alles so dranhängt. Flottenmanagement, sicherlich auch viele sicherheitsrelevanten Systeme, Alarmanlagen, Lokalisierungsdienste etc.
In der Zukunft das komplette Smart Grid, also die Steuerung unserer Stromversorgung. Das ist ja nicht unerheblich. Immer mehr kritische Systeme verlassen sich auf die Dauerverfügbarkeit von vor allem mobilen Datenverbindungen.
Und dabei auch vor allem auf GSM und GPRS. Eigentlich gar nicht so sehr auf UMTS, was jetzt immer so, was weiß ich, im Smartphone-Diskussion. Klar, da will man immer schneller, höher, weiter. Das ist ja so Bleeding Edge, aber GSM hat ja auch den Vorteil, dass es eigentlich ganz gut abgehangen ist. Eine zuverlässige, billig zu bauende Technologie ist.
Ja, und viel weiter verfügbar ist. Wenn ich mir als Stromversorger überlege, wie erreiche ich meine 20 Millionen Kunden, dann ist UMTS im Grunde ausgeschlossen.
Ist ja eigentlich eine richtige Rest-Risikodiskussion, oder?
Unbedingt, ja.
Und an der Stelle ist es doch auch, ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr ins Politische abgleiten, aber man will ja nun eigentlich mit Verständnis vom Internet, also was sozusagen da die Realität ist, möchte man ja gar nicht wahrhaben, dass so ein Provider sagen kann, ach naja, was für Updates, pff, haben wir noch nie gemacht. Aber es stimmt schon, was du sagst. Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo es nur um den Kunden geht und seine Sicherheit, es ist ihnen scheißegal, weil das bringt kein Geld, kostet nur Geld. Aber DDoS, das ist ja nun auch im Internet ein echtes Thema. Ist das nicht, ich meine, wie real ist das?
Ich kann nur auf den Forschungsindizien argumentieren, aber da ist im Grunde jede Basisstation, die jemals von falsch programmierten Telefonen konfrontiert wurde, ist zusammengebrochen. Jede.
Es gibt ja auch nicht so viele unterschiedliche.
Es gibt die drei, vier Zulieferer, die haben vielleicht jeweils drei, vier Generationen an Basisstationen. Und das ist dann das komplette Ökosystem. Also jemand in einer konstantierten Aktion mit…
Ein Telefon reicht, um eine Basisstation abzuhängen?
Ja, es gibt sogar schon Angriffe, die auf besagter DeepSec-Konferenz, ich glaube jetzt vorletztes Jahr gezeigt wurden, wo ein Telefon sogar gleich mehrere Basisstationen abschießen könnte, indem es pro Basisstation sich immer alle Kanäle zuweist. Da hat man es nicht mal mit einem Softwareproblem auf der Basisstation zu tun, sondern einfach mit einem Protokollfehler. Die Basisstation macht an der Stelle nichts falsch. Und trotzdem schafft es dieses eine programmierbare 10-Euro-Telefon, eine oder teilweise sogar mehrere Basisstationen in die Knie zu bringen. Also von denen ein paar über Berlin verteilt und als Zeitbombe zur gleichen Zeit aktiviert, würde schon einen sehr spürbaren Effekt haben bei minimalem Investment. Also jede Aktivistengruppe, die in die Richtung eines politischen Statements machen würde, hätte da einen schnellen Erfolg.
Und wie schwierig ist es für den Provider, diese abgestürzten Basisstationen wieder zum Laufen zu bringen? Was sind da so die Forschungserkenntnisse?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Da stecke ich wahrscheinlich zu wenig tief drin in den Operations der Netzbetreiber. Was ich weiß, ist, dass die Basisstation, mit der wir es zu tun haben, mehrere Minuten Reboot brauchen. Selbst wenn man direkt dran wäre und direkt, vielleicht sogar per Fernwartung, ein Reset durchführen könnte, hätte man zumindest mal mehrere Minuten kein Netz.
Aber es ist ja auch so, dass in dem Moment, wo sie wieder online sind und dieses Telefon wieder machen, werden sie wieder abgeschossen. Das heißt, man müsste eigentlich losgehen und versuchen, zu finden, welches Telefon... Also man müsste erst mal wissen, dass es von einem Telefon überhaupt ausgeht, dass nicht irgendein anderes System Versagen vorliegt. Und wenn man jetzt sozusagen den... Ich versuch das jetzt mal so ein bisschen als Terrorismus-Experte zu beobachten. So, dann müsste man ja quasi losgehen und das Telefon, was da den Ärger macht, lokalisieren. Dazu müsste man erst mal wissen, welches es ist. Also man muss wissen, dass es eins ist, welches es ist und wo es ist. Das kann irgendwo in der Mülltonne liegen und vor sich hin funken.
Das ist, wenn das Telefon keine Dummheiten begeht, also sich irgendwie in einen Silent-Call-Swing lässt mit hoher Sendestärke oder sowas, ist allein das Finden des Telefons hochaufwendig.
Weil man halt ja auch funktionierende Basisstationen dafür bräuchte, um diese Triangulation zu machen und da die Dinge ja dann die ganze Zeit abstürzen, steht ja in einem diese Quelle auch nicht zur Verfügung.
Und stell dir ein Szenario vor, wo jemand solche Telefone in den S-Bahnen, der Ringbahn zum Beispiel, unterbringt. Das ist zudem noch ein bewegtes Ziel.
Naja, das wäre dann aber schon so ein bisschen der Punkt, wo der Gesetzgeber sagen könnte, hier haben wir eine kritische Infrastruktur. Geht ihr Job dann?
Ja, dann wären wir an einem ähnlichen Scheideweg, denke ich, wie mit Windows-Systemen in den 90ern, wo klar war, du steckst deinen Windows-Computer ans Internet und du hast innerhalb von 40, 50 Sekunden Virus. Das war ja auch ein massiver Angriff auf kritische Systeme. Windows ist ja wirklich geschäftskritisch in fast allen Ländern der Welt. Und das hat, denke ich, bei Microsoft zu einer sehr scharfen Kehrtwende geführt und hat da etliche Jahre allerdings gebraucht, bis eine echte Besserung eingetreten ist. Ich könnte mir bei GSM nicht vorstellen, dass das von der Einsicht, die ja noch nicht eingetreten ist, dass man ein leichtes Ziel ist, dass es da einen schnelleren Weg zu sicheren Systemen gibt. Also auch das würde noch viele Jahre dauern.
Gerade weil jetzt die Technik sozusagen schon out of service ist und die Techniker schon alle gefeuert oder in Rente gegangen.
Genau, weil halt der Investitionsstrom nach GSM komplett abgeäppt ist. Die Investments sind alle in der Vergangenheit. Im Grunde ist das abschreibungswürdiges Material heute. Aber dennoch gibt es mehr und mehr und mehr Bedarf an Sicherheit in GSM, dadurch, dass sich neue Systeme, wie es erwähnt, Industrie, Automation und sowas alles heute auf GSM verlässt, wo das vor wenigen Jahren noch nicht der Fall war. Wo man im Grunde immer allein schon aufgrund der Kosten immer noch ein Festnetztelefon daneben hatte. Heute ist der Bedarf an GSM sicher weit höher als jemals zuvor. Trotz, dass wir UMTS mittlerweile haben. UMTS füllt ja maximal mal die Bedarfslücke, die entstanden ist, seit es UMTS gibt. Also sprich, man kann GSM gar nicht abschalten, selbst wenn man ein deutschlandweites UMTS-Netz hätte. Wir telefonieren ja seitdem drei-, vier-, fünfmal so viel. Insoweit brauchen wir drei-, vier-, fünfmal so viel Kapazität. Insoweit sind sowohl GSM als auch UMTS heute nicht mehr abschaltbar.
Ich will jetzt diese Atomkraft-Bezüge und Anspielungen nicht ausufern lassen. Aber wir nehmen jetzt hier gerade den Podcast auf, mitten zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo in Japan gerade die Scheiße so hochkocht, dass man sich eigentlich nur noch an den Kopf fassen möchte. Wir wissen nicht, was dabei rauskommt, aber derzeit sieht es so nach dem maximalen Fuck-up aus, den man sich auch nur irgendwie vorstellen kann, beziehungsweise eigentlich auch schon nach dem, was man sich schon nicht mehr vorstellen kann. Aber ich meine, so wie da alle überrascht waren von so, ah, ein Tsunami kann auch mal zehn Meter hoch sein, und Holla die Waldfee auf einmal unsere Technik weg. Genauso könnte sich ja hier so eine Art Mobilfunk-Tsunami entwickeln, mit solchen Szenarien, wie wir sie jetzt schon angedacht haben, oder sonst irgendwelchen Szenarien, die noch gar nicht bekannt sind. Und dann ist es irgendwie richtig Schicht.
Ja, in der gleichen Größenordnung natürlich wird es auf GSM keine Probleme geben.
Es hat jetzt keine unmittelbaren gesundheitlichen Folgen, aber es ist, sagen wir mal so, für die Wirtschaft auf jeden Fall nicht unerheblich.
Ich denke schon. Und was zurzeit dieses Szenario scheinbar noch verhindert, ist, dass sich niemand findet. Zum Glück muss man sagen, dem es ein Anliegen ist, die GSM-Netze auszuschalten. Die technische Grundlage wäre geschaffen, um mit sehr wenig Arbeit diese kritische Infrastruktur angreifen zu können. Also es fehlt der Feind. Aber genauso hätte man sich wahrscheinlich vor zehn Jahren nicht vorstellen können, dass im Grunde jedes Internetsystem unter zyklischen Denial-of-Service-Angriffen leidet. Wer hatte ein Interesse an Denial-of-Service? Das ist für mich bis heute schleierhaft. Vielleicht noch mal Corner-Cases, Erpressung von Online-Casinos und so was ausgeschlossen.
Gelangweilte 14-Jährige.
Ja, das scheint der Fall zu sein. Genau. Insoweit ist vielleicht diese Feindesmodellierung das nächste, was man machen müsste. Sich mal überlegen, ob es vielleicht ein Corner-Case genau diese 14-Jährigen gibt, die die GSM-Netze irgendwann angreifen wollen würden. Und wenn das auch nur mit einem zahlhaften Ja zu beantworten ist, dann muss was dafür getan werden, diesen Angriff proaktiv zu verhindern. Also irgendwann wird er kommen und die Größenordnung skaliert wahrscheinlich genau nur mit der Langeweile der Leute, die es machen.
Ja, oder halt der anderen klassischen Terrorproblematik. Wer hat Interesse, Flugzeuge in Hochhäuser zu fliegen?
Terror wäre wahrscheinlich ein anderer möglicher Angreifer. Vielleicht aber auch einfach Geschäftsschätting, das Verhalten. Dass sich ein Ausländer oder Konkurrent überlegt, welches deutsche Unternehmen.
Fahren wir doch mal die deutsche Wirtschaft runter. Macht sich bestimmt gut auf dem Aktienmarkt.
Ja, die Deutsche Bahn zum Beispiel verlässt sich enorm auf GSM für die Steuerung ihrer Züge. Da hättest du direkt eine andere kritische Infrastruktur gleich mit lahm gelegt. Wahrscheinlich nicht bis zur Zugentgleisung oder ähnlich Schlimmes. Aber allein mal Züge nicht fahren zu lassen, ist ja auch schon mal ein enormer wirtschaftlicher Schaden.
Du bist ja so Doktor und alles, arbeitest auch bei angesehenen Instituten. Dir müssen die Leute ja schon so ein bisschen zuhören. Du gehst ja jetzt nicht unbedingt sofort als schmieriger Hacker durch, oder? Hast du da nicht so ein bisschen Kontakt mit Leuten, die es eigentlich besser verstehen müssten?
Ja, ja, doch. Viel zu wenig noch. Die Industrie teilt sich da sehr stark Richtung, alles, was nach Hacken riecht, ist natürlich illegal und darf auf keinen Fall auch nur mit einem Gespräch belohnt werden.
Und nicht mit den Schmuddelkindern.
Es gibt dann aber natürlich auch einen sehr offenen proaktiven Teil der Industrie, der zumindest an der, ich hatte gerade erwähnt, an der Risikomodellierung sehr interessiert ist, also überhaupt mal zu verstehen, was denn die Risiken sind. Ich kann jetzt da nicht zu tief eingehen, aber sagen wir mal, ein paar große Institutionen arbeiten wirklich an dieser Thematik. Leider aber nie alle und ich denke mal, zumindest die europäischen Märkte werden in so eine Richtung gehen, dass es manche Netzbetreiber gibt, denen Sicherheit wichtig ist und andere, die immer noch auf Preis spielen. Aber auch das wäre ja keine so schlechte Welt, in der man sich Sicherheit erkaufen darf, wenn man denn will, aber nicht muss, dass jedem die Wahl überlassen wird. Und dass dann bitte der nächste große Industriebetrieb, der seine Industriesteuerung an GSM hängt, dann das sicherste Netz wählt und den Obolus zahlt.
Ja, ich denke mir so, wenn man jetzt ein kluger Provider wäre, sollte man ja vielleicht durchaus das auch mal von der Sichtweise sehen, weil es ist ja nahezu absehbar, dass das, vielleicht nicht konkret so ein Szenario, wie wir das jetzt angesprochen haben, aber irgendwas anderes, was eben sehr weit reiche Folgen hat, durchaus auch mal passiert. Und in dem Moment, sagen wir mal, alle Netze sind unten außer einem. Also ein besseres Verkaufsargument könnte ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Ja, die Provider, die diese Gedanken anstellen, das sind natürlich diejenigen, die sehr auf Qualität setzen. Es ist in Deutschland wahrscheinlich schon klar, welche zwei das sein könnten. Die fühlen sich allerdings in ihren Optionen recht eingeschränkt. Also die Technik nicht selber verantworten. Also man gibt keine Blaupause an Ericsson rüber und lässt sich eine Basisstation bauen, sondern man ist wirklich darauf angewiesen, eins von drei, vier aktuellen Produkten zu kaufen, die auch 50, 60 andere große Netzbetreiber der Welt kaufen. Also man ist nie Primärkunde oder auch nur wichtiger Kunde. Man ist immer nur einer von sehr vielen. Insoweit...
Wie kann er der Erste sein, sozusagen?
Es kann keiner der Erste sein. Es kann wirklich nur ein sehr organischer Prozess sein, in dem es im Grunde global koordiniert wird, Druck auf die wenigen Zulieferer auszuüben, um mal bessere Technik zu bauen. Und ich denke mal, dieser Druck wächst kontinuierlich, hat aber die nötige Schwelle noch längst nicht erreicht. Das Koordinierungsgremium an der Stelle ist die GSMA in London. Die GSM-Standardschreib, die aber durchaus auch sehr stark in der Zertifizierung von GSM-Komponenten usw. tätig ist. Zumindest in meiner Interaktion mit der GSMA sehe ich da doch sehr positive Signale, dass man es ganz doll ändern möchte. Aber selbst die GSMA als Vertreter von 400 Netzbetreibern hat scheinbar noch nicht das Durchsetzungsvermögen.
620 sind es hier laut Müllhalde. Das ist aber interessant. 620 Provider, die nun wirklich alle nicht gerade wenig Geld haben, also manche zumindest. Was ist denn da der Grund? Ich meine, da sollten nicht auch die Hersteller schon wieder Interesse haben. Ich meine, wenn die das ändern wollen, dann ist das ja auch ein potenzielles Business.
Ich glaube, die Einsicht fehlt gerade noch bei den Netzbetreibern, dass Sicherheit ein Qualitätsmerkmal ist, dass wenn heute noch nicht, dann zukünftig Marktentscheidungen mit beeinflussen wird. Zurzeit argumentiert man mit den Netzbetreibern folgendermaßen. Die einzigen zwei Formen der Sicherheit, die für den Kunden vorstellbar sind, ist einmal quasi die ganze iPhone-App-Debatte, wer installiert mir ein Virus auf meinem Telefon, und insoweit komplett in der Verantwortung der Benutzer, zumindest dass ich den Netzbetreiber, oder im Maximalfall in der Verantwortung von Google, Apple, HTC, aber niemals der Netzbetreiber, sodass Handysicherheit heute eine Diskussion ist wie Computersicherheit, nämlich eine Software-Diskussion, und die Netzbetreiber sich dann eher als ISP sehen, der nicht dafür verantwortlich ist, ob du deine Windows-Patches installierst oder nicht. Die zweite Diskussion, die bei den Netzbetreibern zum Glück endlich aktiv geführt wird, ist die des Abgreifens von Handy-Gesprächen. Also man malt sich da ein Szenario aus, wo diese öffentlichen Rainbow-Tables in wenigen Monaten zum, sagen wir mal, War-Driving verwendet werden. Dass man im Grunde die gleiche Größenordnung an Probleme hat, wie Wi-Fi, WLAN, das es in den 90ern hatte. Wo man einfach nur aus Spaß, man hatte ja nie irgendwie was abgegriffen.
Und das ist nicht unrealistisch, oder?
Ja, klar, das könnte jetzt jeder heute machen. Also es wundert mich sehr, dass es noch niemand macht oder zumindest niemand drüber spricht. Und auch an der Stelle fühlen sich die Netzbetreiber ein bisschen aus der Verantwortung herausgestohlen, weil sie bieten ja normalerweise die Option des UMTS, besser verschlüsselten Telefonats, nicht wissentlich auf Seiten der Netzbetreiber, dass die meisten Telefone für sehr viele Gespräche auf GSM zurückschalten. Also man denkt, man hätte jetzt Milliarden in neue Netze mit besseren Sicherheit investiert und hätte damit seine Pflicht erfüllt. Das ist natürlich nicht der Fall, wenn ja gerade schon gesagt ist, dass viel mehr Netzkapazität gebraucht wird als noch vor ein paar Jahren. Und dass vor allem die 3G-Netze natürlich enorm beansprucht werden. Jedes zusätzliche iPhone saugt zusätzlich an den schnellen Datenverbindungen, die über 3G bereitgestellt werden. Und normale Telefongespräche müssen dann auf GSM zurückweichen. Weil GSM halt genau für die Telefongespräche noch zur Verfügung steht, für nichts anderes aber brauchbar ist. Also die Netzbetreiber sehen die Lösung in UMTS. Sie wissen aber nicht, wie man UMTS jemals auf ein ganzes Land hochskalieren könnte.
Weil das Dateninteresse daran so groß ist?
Genau, weil das Dateninteresse so groß ist, aber weil die Technik auch einfach für Städte geschaffen wurde. Eine UMTS-Zelle ist weit, weit kleiner als eine GSM-Zelle im Maximalausbau. Insoweit die ländliche Bevölkerung niemals mit UMTS versorgt werden kann. Außer man deploiert nochmal 30-40 Mal mehr Basisstationen in Deutschland.
Was wiederum keiner bezahlen will.
Genau, dann lieber ein moderneres GSM-Netzwerk. Dann wären selbst die Milliardenbeträge noch vergleichbar gering.
Aber ich meine, der Punkt, der Benutzer wird abgehört, das ist ja nun eigentlich etwas, was keiner will, schon gar nicht in Deutschland. Zumindest ist das immer das Lippenbekenntnis, wie sehr es die Leute dann am Ende wirklich stört, das sei mal dahingestellt. Ich glaube aber, dass es auch ein Problem der Wahrnehmung ist, weil man es einfach nicht merkt. Man merkt nicht, dass man abgehört wird. Man wird ja auch heute schon abgehört. Es gibt auch dieses fatalistische, naja, der Staat hört ja sowieso ab. Und natürlich, der Staat kann natürlich auch zuhören, ohne jetzt die Verschlüsselung über die Luftschnittstelle mitbekommen zu müssen.
Das stimmt. Und ich denke mal, dessen sind sich die meisten auch bewusst. Und genauso ist man sich ja bewusst, dass wenn man irgendwie über web.de seine E-Mail schreibt, dass es auch dann diese Telekommunikationsüberwachung gibt und der Staat, nämlich der eigene Staat, mithört. Ich denke mal, worüber man sich weniger bewusst ist, ist, dass diese Fähigkeit jetzt im GSM-Kontext nicht dem eigenen Staat vorbehalten ist, sondern dass neben dem legalen Abgreifen, nennt sich das ja, the lawful intercept, im Backend des Betreibers, durchaus auch das Abgreifen auf der Luftschnittstelle jetzt möglich ist und schon seit Jahren praktiziert wird von verschiedensten Einrichtungen. Da zählen mit Sicherheit dazu andere Regierungen. Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass zumindest die großen Botschaften hier in Berlin oder auch die deutschen Botschaften im Ausland GSM-Überwachung aktiv betreiben. Ich würde aber nicht ausschließen wollen, dass nicht auch Detekteien und private Sicherheitsdienste sich diese Fähigkeiten angeeignet haben.
Woher? Ich meine, wenn es die Rainbow Tables jetzt erst seit einem Jahr gibt und mehr so in der Hacker-Domäne sind, wo händert man die Technologien?
Vielleicht sage ich gerade nochmal was zum Anspruch dieser Rainbow Tables. Also es ging hier wirklich nie darum, eine bisher für unmöglich gehaltene kryptografische Fähigkeit zu erlangen. Sondern ganz im Gegenteil, es ging immer darum, darauf hinzuweisen, dass es doch so schwer nicht ist. Und das andere ist schon längst machen.
Weiß man das sicher?
Das weiß man. Es gibt ja Konferenzen oder wie nennt sich das? Industriemessen, auf denen Geräte angepriesen und sicher auch verkauft werden, die wahrscheinlich auch auf Rainbow Table basierend GSM knacken. Und das nicht erst seit letztem Jahr oder seit 2007. Das ist ein lukrativer Markt mit mehr und mehr Anbietern, die wahrscheinlich jedes Jahr zu einem etwas geringeren Preis, aber mit Sicherheit immer noch irgendwo sechsstellig wahrscheinlich, GSM-Knack-Equipment an Regierungen und andere Organisationen mit tiefen Taschen verkaufen. Eine einschlägige Konferenz ist zum Beispiel die ISS in Dubai. Eine Konferenz, die sich auch gar nicht versucht zu verstecken. Jedes Jahr werden dort die effektivsten, neuesten, legal und anderweitig Intercept-Lösungen angepriesen. Über die Luftschnittstelle, kabelgebunden, Satellitenkommunikation, was auch immer dein Herz begehrt, um deine eigenen Bürger, aber auch durchaus Bürger in Ländern, in denen du eine Botschaft hast, abzuhören.
Und ISS heißt nicht International Space Station, sondern heißt Intelligence Support Systems for Lawful Interception, Criminal Investigations and Intelligence Gathering. Ja, also um das nochmal kurz zusammenzufassen. GSM, Telefonier, Sicherheit, also die Sicherheit im Sinne von, dass verhindert werden soll, dass jemand das Telefon, was das Telefonat, was ich führe, über die Luft abhört. Also ohne der Start zu sein, ohne unmittelbaren Zugriff auf irgendeine Telekom-Infrastruktur zu haben, wo man sich ja quasi direkt an den Switch hängen kann und da geht das unverschlüsselt durch. Ist möglich, weil dieser A51 Krypto-Algorithmus, der so de facto als der einzige, obwohl es theoretisch mal vier hätte geben, also theoretisch gibt es vier, zwei sind überhaupt nur implementiert worden. Der eine ist noch schlechter als die Eins. Und die Eins ist im Idealfall sogar noch die einzige, die überhaupt noch gemacht wird, wenn es nicht sowieso schon keine ist. Also man ist in manchen Ländern aus Mangel der Unterstützung für den Einser sowieso schon auf keinen angewiesen. Und selbst wenn diese Verschlüsselung läuft, ist genug Wissen im Markt, um einfach Technik zu kaufen. Die schiebt man irgendwo rein, dann hält man die Antenne in die Luft und dann kann man irgendwie mithören. Weil einfach dieser Algorithmus on the fly der Schlüssel gefunden wird und man on the fly diese Verschlüsselung knackt und dann einfach aufzeichnet oder live mithört oder so. Das ist so der Stand der Dinge.
Ganz genau. Und das durchaus auch skalierbar. Also die Rainbow Tables, die jetzt im Internet stehen, verwandeln jeden Computer mit ein paar kleineren Festplatten in eine 30-Sekunden-Knackmaschine. Überlegt, du skalierst das hoch, baust eine Hardware speziell für den Zweck, vielleicht mit FPGAs drin. Da bist du schnell im Sekundenbereich. Du kannst also je weit mehr Gespräche knacken, als du jemals Zeit finden würdest, dir anzuhören.
Oder nimmst einfach 30 PCs. Dazu kommt, und jetzt ist das Problem, ich fasse noch mal ein bisschen zusammen, jetzt würde man natürlich gerne sagen, na hier, guck mal, es gibt doch von dem A5 eine Version 3 und eine Version 4, ich weiß nicht, welche ist die beste?
Der Algorithmus ist, die Algorithmen sind diesmal zum Glück bekannt. Bei A51 war das in der Erschaffungsphase nicht so. Und der Algorithmus ist sogar der gleiche bei 3 und 4, die Schlüssellänge unterscheidet sich.
Also 4 ist dann sozusagen die sicherste Variante?
4 hat dann endlich einen 128-Bit-Schlüssel, wie wir das ja im Internet schon seit sicher 10 Jahren gewöhnt sind.
Ja, so, und jetzt würde man natürlich gerne sagen, okay, lieber Provider hier mit der 1, das ist alles scheiße, alle können zuhören, warum machst du das? Dann können die halt sagen, na ja, aber wir können ja unsere Hardware überhaupt gar nicht upgraden. So, da könntest du zu Nokia gehen und so, das Produkt steht nicht im Regal. Wenn wir wollten, gibt es das nicht. Und dann auch mit dem Argument, na ja, dann biete denen doch Geld. Dann sagen die, na, wir wollen aber so viel Geld haben, so viel haben wir nicht oder wollen wir nicht ausgeben. Oder wenn dann nur, wenn alle anderen auch zahlen oder was auch immer. So, und jetzt hat man das Problem, dass man irgendwie vielleicht erst mal meint, keinen Hebel zu haben, aber wenn man jetzt dieses DEDOS-Argument mit hier eure Infrastruktur und damit unsere aller Infrastruktur ist in Gefahr ansetzt, dann gäbe es ja im Prinzip einen riesen Incentive, das Ganze überhaupt upgradable zu machen. Und in dem Moment könnte man ja dann auch auf den neuen Schlüssel gehen.
Ganz genau, würde man mehr oder weniger automatisch. Also wenn man seine Infrastruktur schon so weit auf den neuesten Stand bringt, dass man Software upgradable wird, dass man die Netzwerkdaten im ständigen Zugriff hat, operational security wäre der Stichpunkt, dann hätte man mit Sicherheit auch A53 automatisch dabei. Die neueren Basisstationen bieten das alles als Paket. Also ich will das jetzt nicht als Aufruf zum startet doch endlich mal den DDoS gegen die deutschen Netze verstehen. Wir sind aber Forschung in die Richtung, würde mit Sicherheit die Evolution soweit anheizen, dass wir bald nicht nur keinen DDoS gegen Netze mehr hätten, sondern dann auch unsere Gespräche und SMS geschützt wüssten.
Zumindest etwas.
Etwas mehr als heute, genau. Der eigene Staat kann dann immer noch dran, aber...
In jedem Fall nur noch der Staat.
Genau.
Und der eigene Provider.
Ja, der darf nicht dran. Der würde es halt vielleicht trotzdem machen.
Klar, wenn es verboten ist, dann wird es natürlich nicht gemacht. Schön, dass wir mal drüber gesprochen haben. Ich denke, das ist ja vor allem auch so eine politische Frage eigentlich. Also so wie man die ganze Diskussion mit kritischer Infrastruktur schützen, ja, hat sich bisher im Wesentlichen so ein Bereich von Kraftwerken gehalten. Man redet auch über das Internet, aber Telefon ist irgendwie selten auf der Agenda.
Immer mehr. Und ich denke mal, die Dynamik könnte eventuell noch genau andersherum betrachtet werden. Das ist nämlich eine ungeschützte kritische Infrastruktur. Und ich glaube nicht, dass die Netzbetreiber ihre Mobilfunknetze wirklich als hochqualitative technische Systeme sehen, sondern eher als irgendwas, was läuft, wo man möglichst viel Geld daraus pressen muss. Also dass man auf einer solchen eigentlich bekanntermaßen wackeligen Grundlage mehr und mehr kritische Systeme baut. Ich glaube, das ist eher das Problem, dass die Erwartungshaltung an GSM auf dem heutigen Stand das wirklich vorhandene Sicherheitsniveau bei weitem übersteigt. Jetzt hatten wir soweit die Optionen durchdiskutiert, da muss halt GSM zu den Erwartungen hinwachsen. Und also angesichts der heutigen Entwicklung wird auch mindestens mal ein Netz das machen müssen, weil plötzlich nicht alle GSM-basierten Anwendungen abgeschaltet werden müssen. Aber die Verfehlung ist durchaus auf beiden Seiten. Die GSM-Netze sind niemals gebaut worden, um plötzlich als Backbone für Industrieautomatik zu dienen. Das war nicht im Raum der Möglichkeiten vor 20 Jahren. Man hat es immer nur als Ergänzung zur Festnetz-Telefonie gesehen und als zusätzlichen Einstiegspunkt in Festnetze für jemanden, der zufällig gerade mal nicht zu Hause ist.
Früher hieß das Autotelefon.
Und hat noch etliche Kilo gewogen. Ich denke mal, dass man es mehr oder weniger als Krücke verstanden hat damals und sich die Netze immer noch auf anderer Seite sicher gewünscht hat. Nämlich wirklich kabelgebundene Netze, datenbasierte Netze. GSM ist ja niemals als datenbasierter Standard designt worden. Man hat alles um die Sprache herumgebaut. Und nur Zusatzstandards wie GPRS, Edge und irgendwann dann 3G als neues Standard haben im Grunde die Welt geöffnet für all diese Anwendungen, die sich heute darauf verlassen. Ich denke mal, beide Richtungen müssen aufgeklärt und verstärkt werden. Also es muss sowohl Klarheit darüber geschaffen werden, welche Risiken man eingeht, wenn man GSM einsetzt. Gerade aktuell gibt es eine Diskussion über GPS, auch eine ganz andere Technologie, die nicht für uns gebaut wurde, sondern für das US-Militär, auf die wir uns aber heute verlassen. Ob das so richtig ist, die gleiche Frage muss man bei GSM auch stellen. Vor allem, wenn man als Bank plötzlich sich auf SMS verlässt oder als Stromversorger auf Steuerdaten, die über einen unverschlüsselten GSM-Kanal reinkommen.
Ja, interessanter Punkt. Lassen wir uns vielleicht auch gleich mal darauf eingehen. SMS existiert immer so ein bisschen daneben, wie wovon hängt die Sicherheit von SMS ab. Ich meine, SMS wird heutzutage, also erstens existiert zumindest das Bild. Einerseits, ich kann mich damit authentifizieren, das ist ja das, was gerade angesprochenen Banktransaktionen etc. auch mitgemacht wird. Es wird zumindest so als so der, das kommt von mir, wie sehr das dann auch noch mit anderen Maßnahmen unterfüttert und begleitet wird, sei mal dahingestellt. Und das andere ist natürlich auch, kann keiner lesen. Was ist denn da der Stand der Dinge?
Ich denke mal, beides ist richtig aus Sicht des Internets. Das möchte ich jetzt gerade mal erklären. Aus Sicht des Internets ist es ja so, dass Nachrichten, die unverschüsset gesendet werden, grundsätzlich überall landen könnten. Dass dann eine Malware oder ein Proxy-Server installiert oder sogar die Daten direkt von deinem Computer abgreift. Dass Leute auf dem Kabel sitzen. Dass eventuell das Zugangsnetz zur Bank kompromittiert ist. Dass also die Internet-Sicherheit davon ausgeht, dass Verschlüsselung immer entweder komplett da ist oder komplett weg ist, also sprich, die Welt mithört. Bei GSM ist die Verschlüsselung jetzt zumindest nicht komplett da. Wir können sehr knacken, wir können auch SMS aus Kilometern abgreifen und auch wieder in wenigen Sekunden entschlüsseln. Aber trotzdem ist es noch kein Angriff wie übers Internet möglich, wo plötzlich ein Bankräuber, ein virtueller, von diversesten Konten Geld erbucht zum Beispiel. Insoweit hat GSM sicher ein Sicherheitsversprechen als zusätzlicher Faktor in Internet-Anwendungen, aber auch nur, wenn es komplett getrennt vom Internet zu verstehen ist. Das war jetzt viel Erklärung, vielleicht mache ich es bildlich. Wenn du deiner Bank eine Postkarte schickst, einfach nur dein Passwort draufschreibst, ist selbst das noch ein Sicherheitsgewinn gegenüber dem Fall, wo du alles nur übers Internet machst. Obwohl die Postkarte natürlich ganz offensichtlich von verschiedensten Leuten abgegriffen werden kann, ist dann der Hacker in Russland nicht dazu in der Lage.
Ja gut, aber angenommen, man hätte jetzt mal solche Träume gehabt, das ist ja nun auch schon viel und tauchen auch regelmäßig wieder auf. Bezahlsysteme, also in Afrika ist das ja auch gang und gäbe, dass über das Handy auch eine Menge finanzielle Transaktionen durchgeführt werden und viel basiert. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie es im Einzelnen immer funktioniert, aber ich vermute mal, SMS spielt da auch eine große Rolle. Jetzt mal erstmal nur so rein technisch. Also wodurch ist die SMS gesichert? Ist das auch A5?
Genau, das ist ja genau der gleiche Verstößungsalgorithmus und ist sogar noch mal leichter zu knacken normalerweise, weil du die Dinge auf Halde mitsniffen kannst und im Grunde nach als Batch-Auftrag durch deinen Cracker jagst, weil bei Telefongesprächen immer noch verschiedenste Frequenzen benutzt werden und das Gespräch da und hin und her hüpft und dein Sniffing-Hardware doch noch mal ein bisschen ausschweifender sein muss. Bei SMS kommt alles kurz und knackig auf einem Kanal. Da ist es knackst, wann auch immer du willst und liest es mit.
Das heißt, wenn ich mein Podcast-Taschengeld nehme und nach Dubai fliege auf die ISS und mir mal so ein schwarzes Rackgerät da kaufe und mich hier in Kudamm stelle, dann würde ich viele Nachrichten sehen.
Genau, da musst du gar nicht nach Dubai fliegen. Da kaufst du dir so ein Motorola C123-Telefon, das dieses osmo.com BB-Projekt reprogrammieren kann. Das ist der Datenkanal, das ist GSM-Daten in dein Computer. Und plus die Rainbow Tables, die es bei BitTorrent gibt, dann bist du schon ausreichend ausgestattet, um mehr SMS einzufangen, als du jemals lesen wolltest.
Dann kommen wir gleich noch mal auf das Projekt, kommen wir gleich noch mal zu sprechen. Aber nur noch mal kurz festhalten. Also in dem Moment, wo A51 geknackt ist für Sprache, gilt es genauso für SMS. Das heißt, die Aussage, SMS ist nicht abhörbar über die Luft, ist falsch, weil es ist abhörbar. Und es ist auch einfach abhörbar.
Genau, in fast allen Szenarien. Also es gibt die technische Möglichkeit, SMS auch über GPRS zu verteilen. Also sprich über das echte neue Datennetz. SMS war ja normalerweise im Steuerkanal versteckt. Und GPRS ist weit schwieriger abzugreifen. Der Verschüssungsalgorithmus ist zum Beispiel noch nicht publiziert. Den meisten Netzbetreibern ist es allerdings völlig egal. Und die schicken SMS trotzdem über den langsamen GSM-Steuerkanal, wo er nur A51 verschlüsselt.
Das machen die Telefone oder das machen die Netze?
Das entscheidet das Netz.
Ach, das Netz sagt, wo das Telefon senden soll.
Genau, welcher Kanal für eine SMS zu verwenden ist.
Das könnte GPRS sein, aber es könnte auch normal GSM sein. Und in der Regel ist es GSM.
Fast immer, ja.
Obwohl es keine zwingende Notwendigkeit gibt, weil man müsste ja sozusagen voraussetzen, dass das Telefon auch GPRS kann.
Genau, das kann man bei fast allen Telefonen. Und man könnte es ja davon abhängig machen.
Welches Telefon es ist.
Genau.
Man weiß ja, welches Telefon es ist, weil man sieht die ID und hat E-Tabellen.
Telefone senden eine recht ausführliche Liste ihrer Fähigkeiten bei der Verbindung zum Netz. Also das Netz weiß immer zum Beispiel, welche Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen vorhanden sind oder auch, ob GPRS vorhanden ist.
Das heißt, im Prinzip würde gar nichts dagegen sprechen, dass die GSM-Netzwähler heute anfangen zu sagen, okay, wenn du GPRS kannst, und das können fast alle Telefone, dann schickst du auch bitte per GPRS.
Genau.
Aber sie machen es nicht. Und warum nicht?
Na ja, eine Liste ähnlicher Beispiele von Low Hanging Fruit, nennt man das, glaube ich, also einfachen Umstellungsarbeiten, die weit mehr Sicherheit versprechen würden, gibt es eine recht lange Liste für GSM. Und die Gedanken dorthin hören bei den Netzbetreibern eigentlich meistens dort auf, wo GSM anfängt. Also sprich, man konzentriert seine kompletten Umstellungs- und Sicherheitsarbeiten zurzeit auf UMTS und LTE. Man hat jetzt mittlerweile drei Netze, die man parallel betreiben will und denkt, bei GSM wäre wirklich nichts mehr zu holen. Im Dezember hat eine Wunschliste von fünf Dingen rausgegeben auf unserem Kongrestalk, die wir gerne dieses Jahr umgesetzt sehen würden. Also fünf Dinge, die extrem einfach, konzeptionell einfach umsetzbar sind in Netzen und die weit mehr Sicherheit versprechen. Da gehören so Dinge zu, wie wenn du eine kurze Nachricht schickst, muss das komplette GSM-Frame trotzdem aufgefüllt werden. Und traditionell benutzt man da ein Füllzeichen. Das gleiche Zeichen, solange bis die Nachricht voll ist. Das macht es einfach knackbar. Stattdessen sollte man Zufallszahlen verwenden. Du kannst dir das als Software vorstellen, wo es dann heißt, das Füllzeichen reinnehmen, eine Zufallszahl stattdessen. Minimale Umstellungen.
Deshalb einfacher knackbar mit festen Füllzeichen, weil umso mehr man über eine verschüsselte Nachricht weiß, wie sie eigentlich ist, umso mehr Annahmen kann man über den Schüssel machen.
Wir brauchen eine komplett voraussagbare Nachricht, um überhaupt unseren Hebel ansetzen zu können. Irgendwo muss man anfangen. Das heißt, wenn jede Nachricht so ein bisschen randomisiert ist, wird das schon reichen. Man würde denken, dass so eine einfache Umstellung schnell umsetzbar ist. Trotzdem, obwohl es ein offizieller GSM-Standard seit 2008 ist, ist es in Deutschland bis Dezember noch nicht gesehen worden.
Also es steht mittlerweile im Standard, dass man das so zu tun habe?
Ja, seit 2008. Einer der Netzbetreiber hat dann im Januar umgestellt.
Im Januar 2011. CRE wird ja auch noch...
Ja, im Januar 2011. Ich möchte was davon träumen, dass es darauf basiert, dass wir im Dezember gesagt haben, dass sie das doch bitte machen sollten. Ich denke mir aber mal, das war eine unabhängige Entwicklung. Aber zumindest ein Netzbetreiber hat jetzt mal die eine Zeile Security Patch aus 2008 umgesetzt.
Du willst jetzt aber nicht sagen, welcher das war?
Nö, da kann ja jeder sich wirklich mit diesem 10-Euro-Telefon selber ein Bild machen. Aber ich hoffe mal, dass das ein Zeichen ist, dass jetzt zumindest die Liste der fünf wirklich Lowest Hanging Fruits abgearbeitet wird und dass dann irgendwann auch über Themen geredet werden kann, wie lass doch mal eine SMS über GPRS verschicken, weil die Verschlüsselung, wenn noch nicht perfekt, dann zumindest viel stärker ist.
Und was sind die anderen niedrig hängenden Früchte, die ihr noch angesprochen habt?
Dass man den Schlüssel vor jedem Gespräch wechselt, dass du niemandem die Chance gibst, quasi ein altes Gespräch von dir oder ein Minuten zurückliegendes Gespräch zu knacken und den Schlüssel im Grunde schon parat zu haben, wenn du jetzt das nächste Gespräch anfängst. Das also sprich, mindestens mal die ersten 30 Sekunden des Telefonats verloren gehend im Angreifer, wenn er 30 Sekunden braucht, um den Schlüssel zu knacken. Was als weitere Forderung oder Low-Hanging-Fruit...
Das bezählt sich aber jetzt nur auf diesen Real-Time-Effekt. Man kann ja alles speichern, den Schlüssel später rauskriegen und dann die ersten 30 Sekunden auch noch dekodieren, oder wird das nicht?
Je nach Ausbaustufe deines Equipments ist es sicher möglich, aber dann reden wir wirklich schon über Millionen Investments. Bevor du den Schlüssel ans Gespräch kennst, ist es nicht voraussagbar, auf welchen Frequenzen das Gespräch passieren wird.
Also, du musst das ganze Spektrum mitschneiden.
Genau.
Also, es ist nicht unmöglich, aber es ist etwas unwahrscheinlicher wiederum.
Also, es gibt irgendwie, je nach Lage, etliche Dutzend bis zu Hunderte von GSM-Kanälen, die auch wirklich in deiner Umgebung genutzt werden. Und die müsstest du alle parallel abgreifen. Das ließe sich sicher auch mit diesen billigen Telefonen umsetzen, wenn du Dutzend oder Hunderte aneinanderklebst und die alle aggregierst. Hat aber noch niemand gemacht. Also, das ist jetzt wirklich der Geheimdienstbereich, wo sehr weitbrandige, sehr hochqualitative Verstärker und RF-Stufen verwendet werden.
Da braucht man dann wieder dieses schwarzleuchtende 19 Zoll Rack aus dabei.
Genau. Aber wenn ich mir die operativen Kosten vorstelle, da tausende Gespräche am Tag mitzuhören, dann sind wahrscheinlich die Investmentkosten gar nicht mal so hoch. Und wenn es dann nur eine halbe Million mehr kostet, dann tut es das halt. Also es passiert, aber es ist eine andere Kategorie. Andere Dinge, die auf der Liste sind, sind die temporäre Identität des Telefons bei jedem Gespräch zu ändern. Zurzeit ist es so, dass Telefone ihre Identität so ungefähr einmal am Tag ändern. Sodass, wenn du ein Telefon jeden Tag an dir vorbeifahren siehst, nicht weißt, dass es immer das Gleiche ist.
Was drückt denn diese Identität aus?
Das ist der Name, unter dem das Telefon an dem Tag bekannt ist im Netzwerk.
Aber überträgt das Telefon nicht eher laufend diese E-Mail, mit dem es eindeutig identifiziert wird?
Nur verschlüsselt. Also sprich, wenn du dich beschränken willst auf ein paar Gespräche, wenn du wirklich nur einmal pro Minute ein Gespräch knacken willst, aber merkst, dass Hunderte von neuen Gesprächen jede Minute reinkommen, dann musst du das Telefon ja irgendwie als Nadel im Heuhaufen finden können.
Und das kann auch der GSM-Provider forcieren, weil der diese Zahl zuweist.
Genau, der GSM-Provider setzt im Grunde die Gültigkeitsdauer oder entscheidet, wann eine neue zugeteilt werden sollte.
Das ist sozusagen so eine Session-ID. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es richtig heißt, aber sowas derart.
Und der Operator, den wir beobachtet haben, dass er plötzlich Random Padding macht, dieses Füllen mit Zufallszahlen, der macht das plötzlich auch. Der ändert die temporäre Identität in jedem Gespräch. Also jedes Mal, wenn du auf eine verschlüsselte Verbindung wechselst, gibt er dir eine neue persönliche Identität, damit, wenn er dich das nächste Mal adressiert, du unter anderem namenbekannt bist.
Naja, das heißt, jemand, der mitlauscht, müsste dann erst wieder herausfinden, welches dieser Nummer, die er da sieht, jetzt auch tatsächlich dein Telefon ist.
Genau, normalerweise beiß ich da die Katze ins Schwanz. Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn er versucht, das herauszufinden, triggert er eine Aktion, die dann wieder zu einem Wechsel führt. Das er immer nur die letzte, aber nie die aktuelle Nummer kennt. Das heißt, dass dann jemand wirklich dazu gedrängt wird, alle Gespräche zu entschlüsseln, mitzuhören, um dann irgendwann das eine Relevante zu finden. Kleinere Maßnahmen, also es geht ja wirklich darum, eine Zahl in der Datenbank abzudaten bei jedem Gespräch, also wirklich minimaler Overhead, wenn man sich überlegt, was sonst alles in einem Telefongespräch dranhängt. Und trotzdem bringt diese einfache Maßnahme schon enorm viel mehr Sicherheit, zumindest gegenüber jemandem, der genau in deinem Gespräch interessiert ist und sonst an nichts. Und die Liste, es ist halt nochmal mit anderen Maßnahmen gespickt, wie zum Beispiel Privatsphärenschutz. Ich weiß nicht, ob du mit Tobias Engel mal drüber gesprochen hast, wie er Telefone übers Internet trackt, über Daten, die im Grunde frei verfügbar sind, wo er dir sagen kann, ob du gerade in Berlin oder Moskau bist. Das ist ein unnötiger Seitenkanal, der einfach abzustellen ist. Und obwohl Tobias da, ich glaube, in 2004 drüber geredet hat, zumindest von den deutschen Providern noch nicht abgestellt ist. Und auch wieder Low Hanging Fruit, da geht es eigentlich nur darum, einen existierenden Standard umzusetzen, um das zu unterbinden.
Da können wir gleich noch eine Werbepause einfügen hier für die tollen Telefon-Podcasts mit Tobias. Also ich vorhin die tollen mit Harald erwähnte, da habe ich sie ganz außen vor gelassen. Aber ganz richtig, zweimal haben wir schon gesprochen hier, CRE 040, langes CA, das ist mir so ein ganzer Überblick, Zeitreise, so um mal diesen ganzen Werdegang von ISDN bis zu den heutigen Systemen zu verstehen und ein bisschen Begriffsklärung zu machen. Und CRE 110, das war schon ein bisschen aktueller, naja also zwei Jahre alt, da ging es halt so um dieses Next Generation Networks, sprich diese Migration zu IP-basierten Technologien. Soweit ich mich jetzt gerade erinnere, kam das auch am Rande zur Sprache. Also da haben wir es auch noch mal gemacht.
Und das ist ein strukturelles Problem der Handynetze. Das hängt also nicht unbedingt an GSM, wird mit Sicherheit mit 3G und LTE weitergehen. Da geht es darum, dass im Grunde die Information geleakt wird, wo sich dein Telefon gerade aufhält, damit dir jeder auf der Welt SMS schicken kann. Weil die SMS wird nicht erst nach Deutschland geschickt und dann irgendwo anders hin, sondern wird direkt dorthin geschickt, wo du dich gerade aufhältst. Und es gibt natürlich die Location-Preise und das Proposal der GSM, auch schon wieder ewig alt, ist doch bitte alles nach Deutschland, und zwar immer genau an die gleiche Stelle zu schicken und dann von dort weiter zu schicken. Also im Grunde ein 2-Hop statt 1-Hop-Netzwerk. Die Liste kann man dann ewig weiterfüllen mit Maßnahmen, wo man sich eigentlich einen Kopf packt, dass die nicht eigentlich schon seit Jahren umgesetzt sind.
Aber du hattest jetzt konkret von 5 Sachen, die ihr benannt hattet.
Genau, ich hatte erwähnt, dass man die TMSI, die ändert den Schlüssel, dass man die SMS über GPRS machen könnte. Genau, das steht auf der Liste schon gar nicht mehr drauf. Das ist dann schon technisch wieder so anspruchsvoll, dass wir denken, dass man da mindestens mal 5 Zeilen Code braucht.
Füllzeichen.
Die Füllzeichen, wir haben über das HLR gesprochen, also wie es die privaten Daten rausgibt. Das letzte, ich schau kurz mal selber nach.
Ich hatte ja vorhin noch kurz gefragt, wie lange du noch suchst. Bei SMS abhören ist das eine, aber richtig knifflig würde es ja erst werden, wenn jemand anderes mich nachbilden kann. Also so tun kann, als wäre er ich. Wie denkbar ist denn dieses Szenario nach dem aktuellen Stand?
Das war irgendwann mal unmöglich gemacht worden, nachdem es kurz mal möglich war. Und zwar war das die ganze Thematik hier Sim-Karten-Klonen. Ich glaube, Thron war da mitführend in der Welt, was Programme zum Sim-Karten-Klonen angeht. Die Security-Problematik um das Klonen von Sim-Karten, also wirklich um das echte physische Duplizieren einer Identität, sind schnell abgeschaltet worden. Da ging es ja auch um echtes Geld. Wenn jemand jetzt auf deine Telefonrechnung telefonieren kann, da hat der Netzbetreiber also ausnahmsweise mal ein echtes Incentive, sicherer zu werden, um die eigenen Einnahmen zu geben. Mittlerweile, jetzt viele Jahre später, ist es doch wieder möglich, die Identität von jemand anzunehmen. Und zwar auf Basis dieser sehr schnellen A51-Knackgeschichten. Wenn du es schaffst, gleichzeitig mit dem Telefon zu reden und mit dem Netzwerk zu reden, kannst du die Authentifizierung vom Netzwerk abgreifen, das Telefon dazu verwenden, den aktuellen Schlüssel zu knacken und dann auf die gerade noch festgehaltene Authentifizierung des Netzwerks zu antworten, sodass das Netzwerk dann denkt, dass wirklich du dieses Telefon wärst. Das ist jetzt ein etwas aufwendigerer Angriff und einer, der zumindest zeitlich begrenzt ist, aber natürlich auch örtlich begrenzt. Du musst in der Nähe des Telefons dich irgendwo aufhalten, der aber dir erlauben würde, mit der offiziellen Telefonnummer dein Opfer SMS zu verschicken oder Anrufe zu tätigen.
Aber diese IMSI-Catcher, die funktionieren doch sowieso schon immer so auf Basis dieser Man-in-the-Middle-Attacken.
Ein IMSI-Catcher macht normalerweise nur den zweiten Teil von dem, was wir beschrieben haben, nämlich einen Kontakt mit dem Telefon aufrechterhalten. Es ist normalerweise nicht so dreist, sich dann auch noch mit dem Netzwerk zu verbinden und dem Netzwerk gegenüber zu behaupten, das Telefon zu sein.
Aber das ginge.
Das ginge, wenn du A51-Schlüssel ausreichend schnell knacken kannst. So eine Authentifizierungssequenz lässt dir…
Ja, aber wenn jetzt häufig die Verschlüsselung schon ausgeschaltet ist, ich meine gegenüber dem Netz kann er doch sagen, ja A51 kann ich nicht. Dann macht er doch eh keine Verschlüsselung.
Das ist eine interessante Frage, ob irgendein Netzwerk in der westlichen Welt das noch akzeptieren würde, weil eigentlich sollte zumindest in den letzten 20 Jahren kein Telefon gebaut worden sein, was nicht A51 verschlüsselt. Also ich würde mal davon ausgehen, dass das Netzwerk dann schlicht nicht mit dir redet.
Das heißt, die afrikanischen Telefone, die nur A52 können, funktionieren gar nicht in Europa?
Ich glaube, die Telefone konnten immer alles, nur wollte man nicht, dass das in Afrika ein Gesamtsystem verschlüsseln kann.
Verstehe. Also die Netze konnten keine A51, aber die Telefone hätten es theoretisch gekonnt.
Genau, genau. Und können es bis heute. Also A51 sollte in wirklich jedem einzelnen GSM-Telefon...
Aber so genau weiß es jetzt auch nicht. Also es könnte durchaus auch sein, vielleicht...
Also vielleicht beantworte ich die Frage andersherum. Ich weiß, dass die, die IMSI-Catcher, die im Markt sind, die mit beiden Richtungen Kontakt halten, dass die dann jeweils auch A51-Schlüsse knacken. Das heißt, dass die nicht, nicht selbst wenn es möglich wäre, unverschlüsselt zu kommunizieren, quasi so auffällig operieren würden.
Sondern die machen einfach die Verschlüsselung, aber das kriegen sie auch hin, dann sind sie auch schnell genug für. Und dann sind sie ja im Prinzip schon so, dass sie eigentlich gegenüber dem richtigen Netzwerk das Telefon repräsentieren.
Genau.
Sie benötigen aber noch dieses Telefon in dem Moment.
Nee, nee. Bis das Netzwerk sich entscheidet, den Schlüssel das nächste Mal zu wechseln, wird das echte Telefon dann nicht mehr gebraucht.
Das heißt, wenn man sich einmal reingehängt hat und der Schlüssel wird nicht jedes Mal gewechselt, wie es heute noch häufig der Fall ist, könnte man im Prinzip danach auch mit diesem IMSEE-Catcher, oder wie das Gerät auch dann immer heißt, eine Verbindung aufbauen und sagen, ach ja, und jetzt wollte ich übrigens noch ein paar SMS verschicken und dann könnte man so ein paar Transaktionen durchführen.
Genau, in Systemen, die sich wirklich auf rein textliche SMS verlassen, weil diese sind normalerweise genau nur A51 verschlüsselt oder halt über GPRS und auch den Schlüssel kriegt man in diesen aktiven Szenarien aus dem Telefon rausgekitzelt. Also dass das Angriffsszenario besteht, durchaus, und ist, ich weiß nicht ob in Deutschland, aber zumindest im Ausland, vor allem in Afrika wieder, frühzeitig adressiert worden. Also Afrika ist uns, denke ich, in GSM sicher ein Stück weit voraus, ironischerweise, weil die immer davon ausgegangen sind, dass ihre Netze unverschlüsselt sind, oder zumindest komplett schlecht verschlüsselt. Insoweit hat man GSM immer als Internet-ähnliche Technik betrachtet, in der du dich entweder um deine Verschlüsselung selber kümmerst oder keine hast. Das heißt Banking-Applikationen, SafariCom hat da so ein sehr populäres, fällt grad der Name nicht ein. Auf jeden Fall im Grunde, dass das mehr oder weniger größte Banksystem, das Afrika mittlerweile, also die meisten privaten Bankkonten in Kenia und angrenzenden Ländern, sind mittlerweile rein auf Telefonen, auf SIM-Karten. Also es gibt keine echte Bank mehr. Dein Operator ist plötzlich die Bank. Solche Systeme sind um SIM-Karten herumgestrickt worden. Kommunizieren über SMS, aber von der SIM-Karte zum Netzwerk verschlüsselt. Und zwar Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt in dem Fall. Also die Bank pflanzt eine Applikation in deine SIM-Karte ein, die dann einen geheimen Schlüssel kennt und ab dem Zeitpunkt können zwar die SMS abgegriffen werden, die dann vielleicht sogar nochmal A51 verschlüsselt sind, aber das ist nicht die relevante Verschlüsselung, weil der Payload selber nochmal verschlüsselt ist.
Das heißt, das sind sozusagen so Super-SIM-Karten, die einfach noch zusätzliche Software über die normale Tätigkeit einer SIM-Karte hinaus tragen?
Würde man denken, dass das irgendwelche speziellen SIM-Karten sind, aber das ist nicht mal der Fall. Also jede SIM-Karte der Welt kann das oder naja, fast jede. Jede, die in den letzten Jahren rausgegeben wurde.
Aber normalerweise befindet sich keine andere Software als die, die das...
Na, da wäre ich mir ganz sicher, die meisten SIM-Karten haben die eine oder andere Software drauf. Ob das jetzt bei der Telekom, ach die Telekom in Deutschland auch, Five Friends, dass du dir eine Liste von fünf Leuten anlegst, zu denen du dann billiger telefonierst. Das ist zum Beispiel eine Applikation auf der SIM-Karte. Oder auf meinem Blackberry kommt plötzlich ein Link auf eine Webseite mit einem Routenplaner meines Netzbetreibers. Das ist eine Applikation, die ist nicht im Blackberry, sondern auf der SIM-Karte, zeigt mir aber ein kleines Icon an, wo ich draufklicken kann. Es gibt mittlerweile Bezahlsysteme, auch außerhalb von Afrika, PayPal zum Beispiel, die haben eine SIM-Applikation, soweit ich das verstehe, wo du dann PayPal-Zahlungen machen kannst. Und all diese Applikationen leben in der SIM-Karte und die Applikationen können, vielleicht ist das ein interessanter Fakt, der noch fehlt, um diese Story verständlich zu machen, diese Applikationen können über die Luftschnittstelle installiert werden, jederzeit. Das heißt, das Set an der Applikation, das in deinem Telefon lebt, ändert sich auch ständig. Und die Installationsfahrt für diese Applikationen ist auch komplett still. Also der Benutzer des Telefons wird nicht gefragt. Die SIM-Karte gehört dem Netzwerk, spricht die ganze Zeit mit dem Netzwerk und tut Dinge auf Weisung des Netzwerks, ohne dass der Benutzer das bestätigen muss. Also neben den zwei Prozessoren in einem Telefon, die man kennt, also einmal der Applikationsprozessor, auf dem dann deine iPhone-Applikationen und so weiter laufen und dem Basebandprozessor, also dem netzzeitigen Prozessor, gibt es ja wirklich ein komplett drittes Computing-System. Normalerweise recht beschränkt, also so eine Standard-SIM-Karte heute hat so 64k Speicher, also Kilobyte schon, aber die gibt es durchaus auch mit Hunderten von Megabyte-Speicher. Also das sind komplette Computersysteme, die da drin existieren, mit Krypto-Prozessoren und allem, was man braucht, um wirklich schicke embedded Software zu schreiben.
Und das ist Realität, dass da Software drauf geladen wird?
Ja, ja klar. Das passiert also in allen Netzen. Es gibt immer kleinere Hilfs-Applikationen, die in der SIM-Karte leben.
Und die Telefone sind so gestrickt, dass sie das einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen und da drauf schreiben. Dann wird diese Software aktiv.
Also den Teil, den wir als Telefon verstehen, nämlich quasi die Applikationsseite, also das iOS oder Android, die bekommen davon gar nichts mit. Das passiert auf einer tieferen Ebene.
Die bekommen, die können davon gar nichts mitbekommen oder die wollen davon nichts mitbekommen?
Es geht völlig an ihnen vorbei. Die können davon nichts mitbekommen.
Weil es sozusagen die normale SIM-Karte-Rede mit dem Netz-Funktion ist.
Genau, ganz genau.
Das heißt, es gibt auch kein Telefon, was davor gefeit ist. Es hängt lediglich von der SIM-Karte selbst ab. Hat man eine halbwegs moderne SIM-Karte, dann kann die das tun.
Genau.
Diese Software ist auch immer aktiv und man kann sie auch nicht daran hindern, aktiv zu sein.
Ganz genau. Und die Software hat unterschiedliche Zugriffsrechte. Das hängt jetzt vor allem von der SIM-Karte selber ab, welche Schnittstellen implementiert sind. Hat aber zum Beispiel in vielen Fällen Zugriff auf dein Telefonbuch. Zumindest in Fällen, wo dein Telefonbuch in der SIM-Karte gespeichert ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch viele Telefone machen, aber früher war das Telefonbuch immer in der SIM-Karte gespeichert.
Das ist wahrscheinlich dann bei den modernen, aber nicht mehr so. Hab ich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen. Also, ich kenne mich da jetzt nicht so gut aus. Beim iPhone ist es, glaube ich, so, dass wenn man einzelne Betriebene in einer Karte, wo Daten drauf sind, dann bieten sie einem das an, noch die Daten auszulesen. Aber ich habe keine Funktion gefunden, wo man es wieder reinschreiben könnte.
Andere Schnittstellen, die in der SIM-Karte drin sind, sind natürlich eine GUI-Schnittstelle, dass der Benutzer etwas angezeigt bekommt. Das ist normalerweise unterscheidbar von dem Rest des Telefons, weil es rein Text-Applikationen sind.
Das müsste aber dann schon explizit unterstützt werden von der normalen CPU?
Ja, die Schnittstelle muss unterstützt werden. Aber das ist verpflichtend. Das hat mehr oder weniger jedes Telefon standardmäßig umgesetzt. Das nennt sich das SIM-Toolkit und das ist je nach Telefon unterschiedlich stark versteckt. Aber wenn du jemals den Fall hattest, dass du eine SIM-Karte in dein Telefon einsteckst und eine unterschiedliche Folge von Menüs hast, als wenn du eine andere SIM-Karte reinsteckst, also das sind genau diese Applikationen, die in der SIM-Karte leben. Bei Nokia-Telefonen, soweit ich das erinnere, wenn ihr einfach im Menü unter den letzten Eintrag hinzugeschrieben, bei iPhones gibt es ein eigenes Untermenü, quasi SIM-Applikationen. Und beim BlackBerry genauso, es gibt einen Ordner mit genau diesen SIM-Karte-Applikationen. Oftmals gibt es zumindest in deutschen Netzen nichts Benutzer-Facendes. Das heißt, die Applikationen, die auf den SIM-Karten drauf sind, verrichten ihr Werk im Stillen oder machen vielleicht gar nichts, sondern warten nur auf Updates, die kommen können oder nicht. Aber der Möglichkeitenraum der SIM-Karten ist schon teilweise erstaunlich groß. SIM-Karten können zum Beispiel Telefongespräche initiieren. Das Programm auf deiner SIM-Karte kann dein Telefon dazu bringen, ein anderes anzurufen. Oder auch nur eine SMS zu schreiben. Wir hatten gerade von diesen afrikanischen Applikationen geredet, die quasi an deine Bank-SMS schreiben. Die ist nicht darauf beschränkt, genau nur an diese Bank-SMS schreiben zu dürfen. Die kann jeder SMS an jeden schreiben. Natürlich immer unter deiner Nummer.
Und ohne, dass ich das merke.
Natürlich, ja. Da bekommst du nichts von mit. Also ein zweiter Benutzer deines Telefons, so kann man sich das vorstellen.
In einem kleinen Chip haupt, den man nicht sieht.
Genau.
Der hat kein User Interface und der hat nicht fragen muss.
Der vieles von dem darf, was du darfst.
Maß an Vertrauen, was man seinem Provider entgegenbringen muss, das ist nicht gering.
Ja, also das Vertrauen geht auch hier wieder wahrscheinlich über das hinaus, was man erwarten würde an Vertrauen. Diese SIM-Karten, also nicht nur muss man ihm vertrauen, dass er selbst nichts Böses macht, sondern man muss ihm auch vertrauen, dass er es so implementiert hat, dass niemand sonst was Böses machen kann. Weil vor allem die Update-Mechanismen der SIM-Karten, wir haben uns die nur mal ganz grob angeschaut, auch die weisen teilweise massive Softwarefehler auf. Also sprich, selbst wenn der Netzbetreiber sagt, ich werde niemals eine böse Applikation in dein Telefon deployen, dann mag der Netzbetreiber in Dubai, der dein Telefon unter seiner Kontrolle hat, während du die ISS besuchst, der mag da ganz anders drüber nachdenken und einen Softwarefehler ausnutzen, der vielleicht in Deutschland eingebaut wurde.
Also er dürfte eigentlich nicht mit der SIM-Karte, also er dürfte eigentlich nicht auf dieser SIM-Karte Software installieren, weil die Karte nicht ihm gehört, sondern die nur zu Gast ist. Aber wenn es einen Fehler gibt in diesem Update-Mechanismus, ist so einer schon mal gefunden worden?
Also es sind Implementierungsfehler gefunden worden, jetzt keine exploitbaren, aber die Code-Qualität scheint schlecht zu sein. Und wenn ich die Indizien mal zusammennehme, ein hochkomplexes Software-System, das auf zigtausenden Seiten Standards basiert, das eine komplette Java-VM unter anderem implementiert, das Schnittstellen in alle möglichen Richtungen hat, das remote-updatebar ist mit optional zuschaltbarer Sicherheit. Und das ist fast der wichtigste Punkt, das noch nie sicherheitsmäßig untersucht wurde von einschlägigen Kreisen. Da würde es mich sehr wundern, wenn man das hier geschafft hätte, aus dem Stand etwas sicheres zu bauen.
Verstehe. Java ist da auch noch drauf.
Klar, die ganzen Applikationen sind Java. Java, wie nennt sich das? Die Mobile, nee, noch eins drunter, Smartcard Edition und sowas.
Jetzt bin ich beruhigt.
Ja, und es ist nicht so, dass alle Netzbetreiber der Welt sich da irgendwie einen Schwur geleistet haben, niemals die Telefone anderer anzugreifen. Gerade in Dubai, wo wir das Thema schon hatten, ist vor anderthalb Jahren mal versucht worden oder sogar erfolgreich, ein Software-Patch auf alle Blackberries draufzuspielen. Also vor allem der Blackberrys, die gerade nur zu Besuch waren, sodass man im Grunde Wanzen in die ganze Welt verteilt. Blackberry ist nicht ganz so einfach updatable wie eine SIM-Karte, also sprich nicht still updatable. Es hat dich dann gefragt, möchten Sie den aktuellen Blackberry Performance Patch installieren und die 20.000, die dann an dem Tag des Deployments ja geklickt haben, die haben sich schon was eingetreten. Ja, die hatten dann eine komplett verantwortbare Wanze drauf, der alle SMS weitergeleitet hat, der die Möglichkeit hatte, jedes Gespräch zu einer Drei-Wege-Konferenz auszubauen, halt mit dem uneingeladenen Gast. Die Software war damals so schlecht geschrieben, dass sie den Command-and-Control-Surfer abgeschossen hat, dass die 20.000 im Grunde zu viele waren auf einmal. Was dann dazu geführt hat, dass die Software auf den Telefonen, weil sie angefangen hat, um Hilfe zu schreien und auffällig wurde, vor allem dadurch, dass sie die Batterie sehr schnell geleert hat. Wäre das nicht der Fall gewesen, wäre das mit Sicherheit erst viel später aufgefallen. Und wäre man in Dubai nicht so dreist gewesen, ist einfach mal auf jedes Telefon zu deployen, sondern nur auf ein paar hundert ausgewählte, wäre es eventuell sogar nie aufgefallen. Also es gibt durchaus schon Netzoperatoren, die sich gegen ihre Benutzer, aber auch besuchende Benutzer, verschworen haben.
Das heißt, es ist generell einfach gefährlich, sich überhaupt nur in irgendein anderes Netz einzubuchen?
Es ist gefährlich, GSM als Technologie zu benutzen.
Und dazu kommt ja auch noch, dass es immer noch keine Möglichkeit gibt, dass das Netz sich mir gegenüber auch zuverlässig identifiziert, sondern ich glaube ja auch einfach, dass es das Netz ist. Das heißt, selbst wenn es jetzt nicht... Wer ist der Betreiber in Dubai? Ist das ET Salat? Das ist einer von denen. Gibt es da mehrere? Ich glaube, es gibt nur einen, oder? Wie auch immer. Ich kann ja auch irgendwo auftauchen, und da ist ein Netz drauf, aber das existiert halt nur im Umkreis von 50 Metern.
Und selbst wenn sich alle Netzbetreiber den Schwur geleistet hätten, sich gegenseitig nicht anzugreifen, dann besteht natürlich immer noch die Möglichkeit des besagten IMSI-Catchers. Dass man jetzt einfach mal sein eigenes Netzwerk baut und sich T-Mobile oder Vodafone nennt. Auch das ist von dem Telefon aus nicht unterscheidbar. Jetzt sagtest du gerade...
Das meinte ich ja im Prinzip. Man könnte jetzt hier durch die Straßen fahren und sagen, hallo, ich bin die Telekom. Und die Telefone buchen sich irgendwie ein, weil sie denken, super starkes Signal. Und dann nutzt man einen Exploit und installiert einfach ein bisschen Software. Und dann ist man schon wieder weg.
Genau.
Und hat etwas gemerkt.
Und obwohl es natürlich Schutzmechanismen gibt, du sagtest gerade, es gibt keine Authentifizierung von Netzseite. Das ist bei Telefongesprächen durchaus so, dass es keinen Schutzmechanismus gibt. Bei diesen Softinstallationen aber durchaus schon. Aber dennoch ist die Beweislage sehr stark in die Richtung, dass auch diese Authentifizierungsmechanismen schlecht implementiert sind. Und vielleicht muss ja nicht jede SIM-Karte knacken, aber jeder Netzbetreiber ändert den Zuliefer aus einer SIM-Karte jedes Jahr. Das heißt, wenn du dir nur mal in Deutschland die Population an SIM-Karten anschaust, hast du da zehn verschiedene Betriebssysteme durch 20 verschiedene Systemintegratoren zusammengepackt, basierend auf 30 verschiedenen Smart-Guard-Chips. Irgendwo wird es da Sicherheitslücken geben müssen. Und sich noch mal vor Augen führt, dass nichts davon Security-reviewed wird, zumindest nicht öffentlich. Und wenn du nur in zwei Prozent der Handypopulation eine Sicherheitslücke findest, sind das immer noch Millionenwerte. Insoweit tickende Zeitbomben auf Technik, die wir nie haben wollten. Willst du deine SIM-Karte updatebar haben, die wir nie nutzen und die trotzdem uns aufgezwungen wird in Deutschland und im Ausland?
Noch mal kurz zu diesem Update-Prozess. Was ist der normale, offizielle Weg? Wenn jetzt ein Update kommt vom Provider, was auf diese SIM-Karte eingespielt werden soll, dann gibt es keine Interaktion mit mir, oder? Aber muss sich denn der Provider zumindest gegenüber der SIM-Karte in irgendeiner Form kryptographisch authentifizieren?
Sollte er schon. Allerdings, wie alle Sicherheitsfeatures in GSM ist, ist das optional. Und der Hersteller der SIM-Karte entscheidet, ob es enforced wird oder nicht.
Gibt es da Erkenntnisse, ob es getan wird oder nicht?
Nee, aber das wäre sicher eine sehr lohnenswerte Forschungsbaustelle.
Es gibt auch einen Fall, wo das so optional ist, dass es bei Default erstmal nicht da ist oder man von Provider-Seite sagen kann, auch heute mal nicht, weil es Sonntag ist. Oder es ist bekannt, dass es eine leicht auszunutzende Schnittstelle gibt. Ich fahre jetzt mit dem Auto durch die Straßen und update einfach mal alles, was bei Drei nicht auf den Bäumen ist, automatisch aus meinem Kofferraum heraus. Ist jetzt nicht ausgeschlossen?
Ist nicht ausgeschlossen. Ich glaube, was nie passieren wird, ist, dass du einen Weg findest, jedes Telefon universell anzugreifen.
Da würden aber so einige bei übrig bleiben.
Ja, dass du eine Lücke in zwei Prozent der deutschen SIM-Karten findest, da gehe ich fest von aus.
Dann kann man zwei Prozent der deutschen SIM-Karten dazu bringen, nur 190 Nummern anzurufen?
Zum Beispiel, genau.
Ich schalte gleich mein Telefon aus. Also habe ich gerade ausgeschaltet.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich eins der Haupt-Takeaways. GSM-Technologie bedroht den Benutzer nicht nur beim Telefonieren. Es ist ein hochkomplexes Computingsystem mit heute viel privaten Daten und so weiter.
Da gibt es aber doch ein echtes Öffentlichkeitsproblem. Ich meine, wenn jetzt im Telefonladen sagen würden, ja, guten Tag, was hätten Sie denn gerne für ein Telefon? Wir haben ja eins, wo Ihr Provider jederzeit beliebig Software installieren kann, ohne Sie fragen zu müssen und die vielleicht Sicherheitslücken hat. Möchten Sie so eins? Dann sagen die doch alle, ich gehe in einen anderen Laden. Aber das sagt natürlich keiner.
Naja, nur leider hat halt das Telefon im anderen Laden genau das gleiche Problem wie jedes andere Telefon.
Das ist nur ein Vorteil, dass der Verkäufer das nicht sagt. Oh, ich atme schwer. Krass. Wie ist denn das? Ich habe gehört, es ist so ein Standard unterwegs, SIM-Karten, die physikalischen SIM-Karten als solche vielleicht in Zukunft mal loszuwerden und durch downloadable images zu ersetzen, dass man so eine virtuelle Maschine eigentlich nur noch in seinem Telefon hat und sich dieses physikalische Reinschieben der Karte sparen kann.
Es basiert auf den gleichen Standards. Ob der Chip jetzt fest verdrahtet im Telefon oder über eine Smartcard eingesteckt ist, macht ja eigentlich keinen Unterschied. Und da selbst die eingesteckten Chips, von denen man ja eigentlich denken würde, wenn sich was ändern soll, schmeißen sie weg, holen sie einen neuen Chip. Wenn selbst die schon software-upgradable sind, dann macht es irgendwann Sinn, das komplett ins Telefon zu verlagern. Aber da ist man heute im Grunde schon.
Gibt es denn Simulatoren für solche SIM-Karten? Also gibt es diese Software, die in so ein Image rennt? Oder sind das dann auch wiederum Hattesteine? Also ich meine, hat schon mal jemand seine Hand an so einen vollständigen SIM-Kartencode bekommen? Ist es möglich, eine SIM-Karte komplett ihre Funktionalität auszulesen und in einem Simulator laufen zu lassen, um dort eine Analyse durchzuführen, was das Ding nun wirklich tut?
Ja und wenn ich das jetzt gerade mal zu einem Aufruf missbrauchen darf, wer Interesse hat, genau solchen Code zu reverse-ingenieren, darf sich gerne bei mir melden. Wir haben da ein paar Exemplare, aber niemals die Zeit, durch diesen ganzen 80-51-Code durchzufärchen. Aber SIM-Karten sind durchaus schon mal ausgelesen worden. Nicht trivial, das sind echte Smartcards, aber selbst jedes Smartcard lässt sich irgendwann knacken und zurzeit sind gerade Infineon-Smartcards und Vogue bei Smartcard-Hackern. Das heißt, ein paar Infineon-SIM-Karten haben wir ausgelesen können. Die Software ist aber hochkomplex. Also da läuft wirklich sehr viel parallel und auch sehr viel Obfuscation gerade in den relevanten Teilen. Das heißt, da steckt noch einige Arbeit hinter, da wirklich herauszufinden, was passiert.
Die SIM-Karten 80-51, hast du gesagt?
Genau, das geht wirklich noch auf einen der ersten Intel-Prozessoren zurück, was das Instructionset betrifft. Smartcarts haben grundsätzlich, glaube ich, die Philosophie, vom Prozessor her nie besser zu werden, aber alle performance-kritischen Teile in Co-Prozessoren auszulagern. Das heißt, der Prozessor ist irgendwie 5% des Dice und umringt von allen möglichen Co-Prozessoren mit Spezialinstruktionen.
Aber so die Hauptsoftware ist 80-51. Und darauf läuft dann das Java?
Da ist dann irgendwie eine Java-VM drin implementiert. Ja, Wahnsinn, gell?
Schnell kann das nicht sein.
Das ist durchaus schnell. Also die laufen eher schnell genug für eine Embedded-Anwendung. Die laufen irgendwie so bei 30 MHz. Und sind halt 8-bit-Microcontroller. Aber starke Pipeline mit Co-Prozessoren für alle Verschlüsselungsfunktionen. Also Verschlüsselung passiert parallel zu deiner normalen Operation.
Ach, da werde ich jetzt wieder ganz romantisch. 8051 habe ich auch mal programmiert.
Soll ich dir mal kurz drüber schieben?
Ich muss zugeben, dass ich nur mit dem C-Compiler drauf gearbeitet habe. Nicht wirklich auf Assembler-Ebene. Von daher habe ich eigentlich keine Ahnung. Aber es spricht mich hier gerade an. Es ist immer wieder erstaunlich, wie lange Technologie sich dann doch hält. Jetzt habe ich sie in meiner Tasche.
Okay.
Glaubst du, dass diese Flashkarten, diese SIM-Kartenlosigkeit sich durchsetzen wird bei den Telefonen? Ist das wirklich so der Standard, der kommt, dass das alles runterladbar ist? Die Provider scheinen da ja nicht das große Interesse daran zu haben.
Es ist ein Machtkampf zwischen den Telefonherstellern und den Netzwerkbetreibern. Und der Machtkampf ist jetzt in den letzten Jahren so ein bisschen von den Telefonen gewonnen worden. Also die Technikführerschaft ist nicht mehr bei den Netzen. Die Netze waren früher diejenigen, die der SMS ermöglicht haben, die dann GPRS und noch schnelleres GPRS, die irgendwann UMTS, die MMS, die jedes Jahr was Neues hatten. Und in den letzten Jahren hatten sie nichts Neues mehr. Jetzt hat aber plötzlich Apple jedes Jahr was Neues. Insoweit verlagert sich die Marke Telefon Richtung Apple, Google und so weiter, die natürlich jetzt sagen, na dann gibt es uns auch den ganzen Rest, nämlich die komplette Benutzerverwaltung. Und die Netzwerkbetreiber sollen sich dann uns eine Nummer schreiben, wir schieben es ins Telefon und dann sind alle glücklich. In welche Richtung dieser Machtkampf entschieden wird, ist reine Spekulation. Aber wenn sich die Netze zu einer Commodity degradieren lassen, sprich irgendwie niedrig qualitatives, unsicheres Zugang zu einem Datennetz bereitstellen und sonst gar nichts, dann ist klar, dass irgendwer anders das ganze Innovationspotential der Technologie ausschöpft. Und ich denke mal, genau in dieser Sicherheitsdiskussion kann man das gut sehen, dass die Netzbetreiber mehr und mehr ISP werden, also einen Zugang geben und sonst gar nichts, als Innovationstreiber sind. Vielleicht kippt es aber auch mit der sich jetzt Diskussion um. Und die Netzbetreiber merken, dass nur sie auf den ganzen Daten sitzen, um größere Gefahren zu verhindern, um Benutzer echt zu schützen. Apple kann ich nicht von der Spyware schützen, die schon auf deinem Telefon ist. Der Netzbetreiber könnte das aber durchaus.
Weil es auf der SIM-Karte ist?
Nicht unbedingt auf der SIM-Karte, wirklich sagen wir mal auf deinem iPhone. Also wir hatten ja gerade gesagt, es gibt die Spyware, die jede SMS auch an eine andere Nummer schickt. Oder die jedes Telefongespräch zu einer Dreierkonferenz umbaut. Das sind Indizien, die sind auf Netzseite natürlich sichtbar. Wer hat denn nur Dreierkonferenzen? Das ist ja völlig unnormales Telefonverhalten. Also Netzbetreiber könnten sich wieder zur Innovationsführerschaft hocharbeiten und könnten sich ja auch den Anspruch auf die SIM-Karte und die Benutzerdaten erhalten versus Apple, Google und so weiter.
In dem Moment, wo diese Dreierkonferenz von Software auf der SIM-Karte ausgeführt wird, ist das Telefon ja machtlos.
Ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, dass das Telefon sowieso machtlos ist. Dass ich aber jetzt irgendwen anders haben will, der mir sagt, schau doch mal bitte auf dein Telefon, da passt irgendwas nicht zusammen.
Ja, so ein Monitoring, ganz klar.
Ein Monitoring auf Netzseite, auf Anomalien.
Aber als Telefonhersteller hätte ich ja eigentlich überhaupt gar keinen... Ich meine, was sollte das Interesse eines Herstellers von Telefonen, Apple, HTC, wer auch immer, sein, dass diese SIM-Karten, diese Software-Installationsmöglichkeit haben, wenn das ein potenzielles Sicherheitsloch ist, was dann unter Umständen auf sie zurückfällt?
Ach so, ja, ganz klar. Das hatte ich auch versucht, so zu argumentieren, dass Apple, Google enormes Interesse dran haben, sich die SIM-Karte einzuverleiben und im Grunde Teil des existierenden kontrollierten Ökosystems zu machen.
Na gut, aber sie haben ja dadurch noch keinen Einfluss darüber, wie diese SIM-Karte funktioniert. Sie laden ja nur das Image über das Netz da rein und exekutieren es nach wie vor als dritte CPU.
Ja, also spätestens, wenn wir an dem Punkt mal angekommen sind, dann sagt Apple doch auch, die SIM-Karte kann nichts, was wir nicht auch über den App Store runterladen können. Die SIM-Karte stirbt, also zumindest als Processing-Kern. Also wird wirklich nur noch Schlüsselspeicher werden. Was ja die ursprüngliche Idee der SIM-Karte war. Den Schlüssel in einem Papierumschlag zum Benutzer zu tragen.
Also das hält so für möglich, dass in dem Moment, wo das Software kontrolliert ist von außen, dass man diese SIM-Karte klein hält, dass sie wirklich nichts anderes tut als das.
Genau, also spätestens, wenn es wirklich mal eine Übereinkunft gibt, das ins Telefon zu nehmen, dann diskutiert man natürlich auch nochmal, welche Standards müssen dann rein? Muss es wirklich noch die Modem-Schnittstelle haben, um Telefongespräche zu machen? Brauchst du noch Zugriff aufs Adressbuch? Brauchst du überhaupt noch Speicher für ein Adressbuch? Also da wird denke ich sehr viel an Features gestrichen werden.
Und das ist das, wovor die Provider natürlich Angst haben?
Na die Provider haben Angst davor, dass sie die Kontrolle über die Benutzer verlieren, dass der Benutzer nicht mehr dem Provider gehört, sondern an Apple und dass du im Grunde Apple anrufst und sagst, ich will jetzt von wo davor in unser Telekom wechseln.
So wird es auch kommen, denke ich mal.
Das ist ja genau die Diskussion. Innovationsführerschaft. Im Moment sind die Telefonhersteller Innovationstreiber, aber zumindest sicherheitsmäßig, denke ich mal, sind es die falschen, weil sie an der falschen Stelle im Netz sitzen, um viel Einfluss zu haben. Also jeder muss Richtung Sicherheit pushen, aber die Netzbetreiber werden die natürliche Heimat für jemanden, der sich für die Gesamtsicherheit verantwortlich fühlt.
Jetzt hast du ja festgehalten, es gibt drei CPUs in den GSM-Telefonen. Eben die normale CPU, die das eigentliche US, das was man so in der Regel sieht, macht. Deren Sicherheitsaspekte sind Betriebssystemdiskussionen, die jetzt hier so nicht unmittelbar reingehören. SIM-Card haben wir jetzt gerade gemerkt, führt ein ziemliches Eigenleben. Aber es gibt ja noch den dritten, die Baseband-CPU. Also da, wo der Code läuft, der sich direkt mit dem Netz unterhält. Das ist ja nun auch ein ziemliches Eigenleben.
Das ist von der Natur her auch genau ein separater Chip. Allerdings einer mit einem ganz anderen Anspruch als die SIM-Card. Vor allem ohne den Anspruch erweiterbar zu sein. Also der Baseband-Prozessor will alle aktuellen Standards möglichst sauber umsetzen und das auf einen möglichst billigen Chip. Also man könnte das im Grunde hart vertraten und die Telefonhersteller wären glücklich.
Das haben sie früher auch gemacht, oder?
Genau, das waren früher wirklich sehr spezialisierte Chips, die dann viel Single-Processing machen, also DSP-Funktionalität, ein bisschen Krypto als Hardware dran. Und die Daten von der Luftschnittstelle nehmen und an die Applikation weiter werfen. Und nichts anderes, den ganzen langen Tag. Die Standards sind seitdem natürlich beliebig komplex geworden. Also es gibt immer mehr Standards, die in jeden Chip rein müssen. Zusätzlich packt man da mittlerweile Bluetooth und Wi-Fi gleich mit rein. Also es wird so eine eierlegende Vollmilchsau. Und die Komplexität plus den Push zu immer mehr Features, immer schneller hat dazu geführt, dass das echte CPU-Systeme geworden sind. Also kleinere Prozessoren, die eine Software abarbeiten und maximal noch Hilfsprozessoren haben für die wirklich schweren Aufgaben. Also einen kleinen Hilfs-DSP, vielleicht noch einen kleinen Hilfsprozessor für die Krypto. Und dadurch, dass es jetzt plötzlich Software ist, werden die gleichen Fehler gemacht wie bei jeder anderen Software. Und man kann auch plötzlich diese Protokoll-State-Machines angreifen und so zum Beispiel Buffer-Overflows führen. Und genau das ist letztes Jahr erstmalig, also im Jahr 2010, erstmalig öffentlich demonstriert worden von Ralf-Philipp Feimann, im Moment an der Uni Luxemburg. Wie man Pakete in das Telefon aus der Luftschnittstelle initiiert, um diesen Baseband-Prozessor entweder zum Absturz zu bringen oder, schlimmer, um Kontrolle über den Baseband-Prozessor zu erlangen und sogar neue Software zu installieren auf diesem Prozessor, wo eigentlich nichts installiert werden soll. Oder mindestens mal Features anzuschalten, die vorher nicht angeschaltet waren. Sein Szenario war eigentlich ein sehr überzeugendes. Er verbindet sich mit seinem Immensee-Catcher zum Telefon. Er hat das umgesetzt für iPhones, Androids und so weiter. Also verbindet sich mit deinem Smartphone aus Versehen für nur mal eine Sekunde zusammen, Immensee-Catcher. Er schickt dir Pakete, die den Auto-Answer-Modus anstellen, der also automatisch dran geht, wenn dich jemand anruft, und setzt gleichzeitig einen Filter, das nur bei einer bestimmten Nummer zu machen. So, zwei, drei Sekunden maximal reichen.
Und schon waren alle iPhones und alle Androids zwar Fernmikrofone.
Fernmikrofone, genau. Wenn er die Nummern jetzt anrufen wollte oder angerufen hat, haben die sich wirklich in eine Wanze verwandelt. Und natürlich ein schockierender Angriffsfahrt, weil er so einfach war und weil ein Forscher an der Uni das irgendwie in einem Jahr Arbeit aufarbeitet, kann sich vorstellen, was für Geheimdienstinteresse an sowas bestehen würde und wie viele Ressourcen die da investieren würden. Und das zündet natürlich eine ganz andere Security-Diskussion im gleichen Kontext nochmal an, wie da eine Umkotqualität und Umwartbarkeit, Upgradebarkeit und so weiter. In modernen Telefonen sind die Baseband-Prozessoren mittlerweile upgradebar, weil sie immer mehr Features und immer weniger Bugs haben wollen. Und iPhone-Updates zum Beispiel haben häufiger mal so ein Baseband-Update dabei. Bei älteren Telefonen ist das nicht der Fall. Also wenn du da einen Fehler im Baseband-Prozessor findest, wird der Fehler erst mit Verschrottung des Telefons sterben. Das heißt, dass man hier, ähnlich wie auf Netzseite, eine unüberschaubare Menge potentieller Angriffsvektoren hat, die die Privatsphäre der Benutzer extrem beeinflussen oder sogar im Maximalfall die Daten des Telefons preisgeben.
Da fragt man sich, was eigentlich schlimmer ist. Ein Telefon, das sich nicht updaten lässt und seinen Fehler auf ewig behält, aber zumindest keine neuen dazu bekommt, die auch noch so flexibel auslegbar sind. Oder eben ein updatbarer Mechanismus, wo der Update-Mechanismus selber ausgehebelt wird, sodass man dann so abgefahrene Software sich auf das Telefon geschaufelt bekommt, dass man überhaupt nicht mehr her der Lage ist. Früher diese Frage, kann jemand von außen mein Telefon als Mikrofon einschalten? Ich weiß nicht, das kam, glaube ich, beim Club schon vor... Ich weiß nicht, solange es Mobilfunk gibt, gibt es, glaube ich, diese Verschwörungstheorie. Und lange Zeit war das ja halt irgendwie so ein... Na ja, unserer Erkenntnis nach geht das nicht derzeit. Oder es wird zumindest noch nicht nachgewiesen, dass das mal jemals irgendwo gegangen sei. Und das mag wahrscheinlich auch damals gestimmt haben. Aber mittlerweile kann man das einfach ganz klar bejahen.
Ja, auf der DeepSec 2010 ist das live demonstriert worden. Krass.
Wird ja immer schlimmer. Ich schalte mein Telefon gar nicht mehr ein.
Es muss halt schlimmer werden, um einen Aufwachen hervorzurufen.
Wäre es denn, um noch mal zu dieser Infrastrukturdebatte zurückzukommen, könnte man ja fast sagen, um die Sicherheit dieser Netze noch zu garantieren, ist der Betrieb updatebarer Telefone mit aktueller Software erforderlich? Sonst nehmen wir euch vom Netz und alte Telefone werden nicht mehr funktionieren. Wäre das ein vorstellbarer Schritt? Ich meine, da müsste man wahrscheinlich auch 1000 Geräte auseinanderschrauben, die irgendwo fest eingebaut sind und pipapo und Ausnahme.
Das ist halt eine Frage der Umgebarkeit dieser Maßnahmen. Jetzt müsste das Telefon attestieren können, eine bestimmte Firma, garantiert keine andere und keine Erweiterung zu haben. Also sprich einen sehr tief sitzenden DRM-Algorithmus haben, der nicht aushilbebar ist. Zurzeit ist alles DRM auf allen Telefonen ausgehebelt. Es gibt kein iPhone, das jetzt noch nicht jailbroken wäre. Beweisbarkeit in mobilen Kräten gibt es schlicht nicht. Sobald es den Benutzer gibt und er daran rumlöten kann, sind alle Geheimschlüssel raus. Mittlerweile hat es selbst auch SIM-Karten, die immer als der heilige Kral kalt, Smart Cards, eine deutsche Personalausweisung oder was auch immer. Alles diese unangreifbaren Systeme, die dann ein paar Jahre später doch angegriffen werden. Und SIM-Karten gibt es jetzt nun mal nicht erst seit gestern.
Da kommt der SIM-Karten-Tonami und dann war es das. Was kann man denn machen?
Was hat man bei Computern gemacht, um von einem komplexen, unbeherrschten Softwaregetüm zu heute Maschinen zu kommen, die sich im Internet zumindest halbwegs sicher fühlen und die wichtige Daten speichern? Ich denke, was auch immer bei Computern geholfen hat, wird bei Telefonen auch funktionieren. Das ist eine ständige Evolution, bestehend aus bewusster Analyse, gewollter Analyse offenlegen, von Schnittstellenanalyse durch Forscher und dann dem Ständigen besser werden wollen. Da gehört sich eine Upgradebarkeit dazu. Es hängt aber natürlich auch an einer Parallelentwicklung. Zurzeit bei Computern hat stattgefunden, was Microsoft nie gedacht hätte, dass die Benutzer gesagt haben, wir wollen mehr Sicherheit bei GSM. Wir sagen das jetzt, vielleicht der überwiegende Teil der Zuhörerschaft sagt das, aber der überwiegende Teil der Telekom- und Vodafone-Kunden sagt das noch nicht.
Weil sie sich dieser Problematik überhaupt nicht bewusst sind.
Genau, oder weil sie einfach kein Licht am Ende des Tunnels sehen können. Sie einfach sagen, die Telefone sind gehackt und damit war es das. Die diesen evolutionären Gedanken nicht verstehen, dass genau aus der Arschwiese etwas Besseres hervorsteigen könnte. Das sind die Hauptentwicklungen, dass mehr Forschung, aber auch mehr Offenheit auf der anderen Seite, mehr Grundlage für Forschung zu schaffen, gebraucht wird, um es technisch besser zu machen, dann aber mehr Bedarf an besserer Technik erst mal geschaffen werden muss, durch Kunden, durch die Leute, die Telekom und Vodafone immer noch ein paar Milliarden im Jahr zahlen, um dieses Netz zu betreiben.
Das muss man sozusagen darauf hinweisen. Da kommen wir wieder auf den Punkt Open Source und Verifizierbarkeit. Du hast ja vorhin schon erwähnt, das aktuelle Projekt von Harald. Was heißt das nochmal genau? OsmoCom BB, das steht wofür?
OsmoCom ist sein Umbrella-Name. Ja, weiß ich gar nicht, ob es da eine Wurzel zu gibt. Das ist mittlerweile der Name für alle AF-Projekte, die aus der Ecke Harald Welte kommen. Und BB steht dann für Baseband. Also genau dieser Zweite der drei Prozessionen, über den wir geredet haben. Derjenige, der die Mobilkommunikation aufrechterhält und Daten aus dem Netzwerk verarbeitet.
Auf was basiert das? Ist das jetzt nicht komplett aus dem Nichts entstanden?
Ich glaube, es ist aus dem Nichts rekreiert worden. Vielleicht zwei Sätze weiter ausgeholt. Diese Baseband-Prozessoren sind hochproprietär, wenn halt genau nur für Telefone gebaut und dann an drei, vier Hersteller ausgegeben. Und genau nur die Hersteller kriegen dann auch die Daten, die nötig sind, um die zu programmieren. Mittlerweile konzentriert sich das ein bisschen mehr auf vor allem Qualcomm und Texas Instruments. Also es gibt da zwei große Hersteller dieser Baseband-Prozessoren, bei denen bis Sekunde, oder du weißt halt nicht, wie man sowas programmiert. Jetzt ist zufällig der Sourcecode eines älteren Texas Instruments-Chips ins Internet gestellt worden. Und der Sourcecode erklärt natürlich sehr gut, wie so ein Chip funktioniert. Und auf Basis dieses Sourcecodes und ein paar andere Informationsfragmente haben dann Harald und Kollegen eine Open-Source-Firmware geschrieben, die im Grunde ähnliche Funktionalität abdeckt, aber in vielerlei Hinsicht weiter ausbaubar ist. Die also ein Telefon auch dazu bringen kann, außerhalb des Standards zu operieren. Wir benutzen das unter anderem dafür, ein Telefon dazu zu bringen, die Daten mitzuschneiden, die an ein anderes Telefon geschickt werden. Das Telefon, das wir haben, zumindest bis wir den Schlüssel geknackt haben, also nicht entschlüsseln kann, trotzdem wollen wir die Daten sehen. Und das ist mit einem normalen Telefon nicht möglich. Diese Programmierschnittstellen geben die iPhone- und Android-Schnittstellen nicht. Soweit gibt es jetzt erstmalig ein frei programmierbares Analysetool, das dir Zugriff auf alle Daten gibt, die vom Netzwerk gesendet werden, die aber, und da sind wir dann wieder bei kritischer Infrastruktur, die erlauben, beliebige Nachrichten Richtung Netzwerk zu senden. Was wir bei IP-Netzen einfach selbstverständlich halten, das war bis vor zwei Jahren bei GSM nicht möglich. Also selbst wenn du wusstest, dass alle Ericsson-Basis-Stationen eine Softwarelücke haben, die auf ein bestimmtes Paket abstürzen würden, hattest du keine Möglichkeit, dieses Paket billig herzustellen. Und mit diesem Programmierband-Telefon ist das jetzt schon möglich.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen ein 1A-Analysetool, aber eben auch wunderbar eine Plattform, um eben auch Sicherheitslücken zu testen und auch auf den Weg zu bringen im Zweifelsfall.
Ja, genau. Es ist jetzt die letzte Obscurity-Mauer gefallen, die zwischen dem im Internet angesammelten Security-Wissen und den GSM-Netzen steht. Und jetzt kann jeder seinen Fuzzer adaptieren, jetzt kann jeder Richtung Ports scannen gehen und versuchen, die GSM-Netze auszuleuchten. Jetzt können die gesamten PEN-Testing-Werkzeuge einfach mal umgestellt werden auf GSM und getestet werden gegen eine Softwarebasis, die im Grunde zumindest die Deployte-Basis, null Source Code Review von Security-Leuten genossen hat. Da kann sich ja jeder PEN-Tester vorstellen, wie schnell man da fündig wird. Also im Zuge der Entwicklung dieses osmo.com BBs sind auch alle möglichen Testbasis-Stationen gecrashed worden. Also sprich, selbst wenn man nicht bewusst sucht, sondern nur mal den Standard aus Versehen falsch implementiert, selbst dann schafft man es schon, die Basis-Station zum Schluck aufzubringen.
Man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie so Baseband-Prozessoren normalerweise entwickelt werden. Da macht man ja bestimmt am laufenden Meter Fehler. Und jedes Mal, wenn man in so einen Fehler reingeht, haut man unter Umständen mal so eben die komplette Infrastruktur weg. Das ist ja schon ein bisschen fett.
Ja, genauso werden die auch, glaube ich, getestet. Dass man jedes neue Telefon mit jeder Basis-Station paart und jegliche Funktion einmal drückt. Und wenn ja nichts abgestürzt ist und jedes Telefongespräch zustande gekommen ist, dann kriegst du den GSM-Stempel. Aber es gibt keinen testigen Richtung. Jetzt hast du mal versucht, was zu senden, was normalerweise nicht vorkommt.
Gibt es denn auch den Fall, also ich erinnere mich ja noch so an die frühen Zeiten, wo es häufig auch so weit ging, das Betriebssystem herstellt jetzt auf PCs, bzw. auch konkret auf Macs. Genau, das ist auch ein schönes Beispiel hier. Apple hat lange Zeit in Mac OS bestimmte Bugs nicht gefixt, weil sie wussten, dass das Quarkexpress in einer bestimmten Version nicht mehr lief. Und da war das sozusagen so ihre Entscheidung, das fixen wir jetzt mal lieber nicht, weil den Ärger wollen wir uns nicht einfangen mit unseren Kunden. Auf der Basis werden heutzutage keine Software-Updates mehr gemacht. Gott sei Dank. Aber es findet sich dann Ähnliches auch in den Netzen. Man könnte sich ja jetzt auch vorstellen, wenn wir jetzt dieses Problem beheben. Deine fünf Vorschläge, wenn wir die jetzt reinbauen, dann funktionieren eine Million Nokia-Geräte aus der Generation sowieso von Version bis nicht mehr.
Die Vorschläge, die es bis zu einem GSM-A-Standard schaffen, die sind normalerweise genau mit dieser Fragestellung schon mal konfrontiert worden. Insoweit gewettet oder geändert worden, dass es eigentlich mit der komplett installierten Basis kompatibel ist. Zum Beispiel dieses Random Padding, das Einfügen von Zufallszahlen. Das funktioniert bei eigentlich allen Telefonen. Bei einem Telefon hat man gemerkt, dass das erste Byte der Zufallszahlen doch nochmal überprüft wird, ob es dieses alte Steuerzeichen ist. Das heißt, man hat den Standard umgeschrieben und sagt, ab dem zweiten Byte nutzen wir Zufallszahlen. Also es wird sehr ausgiebig getestet. Es gibt aber, und da gebe ich dir voll recht, es gibt Konstellationen, in denen der Standard selber die Unsicherheit im Grunde vorschreibt. Wir hatten über dieses hypothetische Szenario eines Telefons auf der S-Bahn geredet, das dann alle angrenzenden Basisstationen in Beschlag nimmt. Das ist ein Angriff, der von Dieter Spahr wiedermals auf der DeepSec 2009 vorgestellt wurde. Der Angriff nutzt keine Implementierungslücke aus, sondern nutzt wirklich ein Feature des GSM-Standards aus. Das kann man nicht abschalten. So funktioniert GSM und so wird man GSM immer angreifen können. Nun kann man natürlich über die rein schwarz-weiß Sicht hinausgehen und sagen, wir versuchen, Fehlverhalten zu detektieren und irgendwie schlaue Filter einzusetzen, um dann bestimmte Messages in Violation des Standards dann doch nicht mehr zu bearbeiten. Das geht aber weit über das Fixen einer Software-Schwachstelle hinaus. Also es geht im Grunde in so eine Richtung der Diskussion, E-Mail ist unsicher, bevor irgendwer was falsch macht mit E-Mail. Jeder hält sich an alle Standards und trotzdem wird alles unverschlüsselt gesendet. Was machst du jetzt? Baust du ein neues System oder schaffst du es irgendwie, E-Mail über PGP, SSL oder was auch immer sicher zu machen? In so eine Ecke wird viel Diskussion mit GSM auch gehen müssen, wo man merkt, dass die Standards unzulänglich sind.
Klingt ja eigentlich alles ganz schön beunruhigend.
Ist es, ja. Und es hat gerade erst angefangen. Das osmo.com BB-Teil war jetzt das letzte fehlende Puzzlestück, um erstmal Zugang zu öffnen für die Forscher. Jetzt können die Forscher anfangen, Forschung zu machen. Im Grunde haben wir jetzt den Forschern erstmalig einen Zugang zum Internet gegeben. Und jetzt können sie mit ihrer ganzen Internetforschung, der 70er und 80er, anfangen. An dem Punkt sind wir mit GSM. Und das Forschungsinteresse wächst exponentiell.
Ja, ist das groß. Man hatte ein bisschen den Eindruck bisher, weil Technologien wie DECT GSM etc. Gut, auch nachvollziehbar, weil wenn es die Mittel, die es in der Welt gibt, nicht gibt, um da zu arbeiten, wie soll man das machen?
Genau, ich denke mal, die Anzahl der Menschen, die bereit sind, ein Projekt wie OpenBTS, BSC oder auch das Ausmachkommen BB zu führen, ist sehr begrenzt. Da ist enormer Fleiß, aber auch Cross-Sector-Expertise nötig, die sich in wenigen Leuten findet. Wenn man jetzt anfängt, darüber nachzudenken, Fuzzing gegen GSM, wie viele Standard-Fuzzing-Tools gibt es? Es gibt eine Implementierung, wo man anfangen kann zu fuzzen. Und jeder IP-Hacker, der sich im Internet mittlerweile langweilt, weil es nichts mehr zu finden gibt, wird es als dankbares nächstes Ziel entgegennehmen.
Also Fuzzing ist dieses Random-Besprühen mit Datenströmen, um mal zu gucken, was passiert.
Genau, bewusst Dinge falsch machen.
Einfach mal gegentreten und gucken, was passiert. Ja, nachdem wir jetzt eigentlich alle Hörer ausreichend beunruhigt haben sollten, stellt sich die Frage, haben wir noch irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen in dem Kontext? Wir sind so von den Netzen zu den Telefonen wieder zurück zu den Netzen gekommen und alles war auch immer wieder aufgehängt in so eine gesellschaftspolitische Fragestellung. Die geht auch nicht weg, sondern die stellt sich eigentlich noch mehr denn je. Gerade im Kontext der allgemeinen Infrastrukturdebatte muss, glaube ich, die Diskussion der digitalen Infrastruktur da auch auf einen ganz anderen Level gehoben werden, als das bisher der Fall ist. Also dieses, naja, installier dir doch einen Virus-Scanner. Da möchte man ja eh als Wissender etwas müde lächeln. So, aber damit es natürlich auf dem Telefon nicht im Ansatz getan, weil es sich ja hier um systemimmanente Schwächen handelt.
Schwächen eines Systems, das nie mit dem Anspruch designt wurde, so erfolgreich zu sein, wie es das heute ist. Also ich denke mal, die Verfehlung liegt nicht in den ersten Tagen von GSM, sondern liegt komplett auf dem Weg seitdem, wo man jedes Jahr erfolgreicher, aber kein Jahr sicherer geworden ist. Insoweit hat sich hier eine Abhängigkeit entwickelt zu einer Technologie, die es nicht verdient hat, von ihr abhängig zu sein. Und vielleicht an der Stelle dann nochmal die Analogie zur Atomkraft. Ich denke, das ist ähnlich, dass jetzt eine enorme Abhängigkeit besteht, obwohl das Wissen über die Unsicherheit sehr groß ist. Die Konsequenzen in GSM werden hoffentlich weit hinter den Atomkraften hinterher bleiben. Aber dennoch ist die Analogie doch sehr stark, das einfach auf Drang des Kunden es billiger zu machen, es weiter und weiter wachsen konnte, ohne qualitativ besser zu werden. Und jetzt sich eine kleine oder hoffentlich wachsende Kundenschaft findet und nach einem sicheren Netz fragt. Aber bis das mal 25% der Deutschen sind, oder zumindest 25% der teuren Business-Verträge sind, kann sich kein deutsches Netz das leisten, diesen Schritt zu gehen.
Wenn man auch noch die Diskussion um den Cyberwar herbeizieht, müsste man ja fast meinen, müsste es ja eigentlich recht einfach sein, da auch ein bisschen Bewegung ins Spiel reinzubringen. Wenn ich jetzt so ein Rogues-Date wäre und ich wüsste darum, wie verwundbar meine Mobilfunknetze sind, dann würde ich doch irgendwie alles tun, wenn man sich so umringt fühlt von potenziellen Feinden, auch nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen, mir auch eine Netzwerktechnologie zuzulegen, die jetzt nicht nur erlaubt, meine eigenen Bürger zu überwachen, sondern die auch einfach absturzsicher ist.
Ich denke mal, der Wunsch ist da an ganz verteilter Stelle. In Deutschland eher bei den Kunden, in anderen Ländern eher bei den Regierungen. Aber dieser Wunsch nach mehr Sicherheit ist bisher nicht aggregiert worden und zu einer Kaufkraft aggregiert worden, die dann einen Ericsson oder eine Nokia Siemens dazu überzeugen würde, was wirklich strukturell Besseres zu bauen. Also der Wunsch ist zu verteilt und auch zu leise. Aber da können wir natürlich alle darauf hinwirken, diesen Wunsch jetzt zumindest mal zu unseren Netzbetreibern zu tragen und dort mal aggregiert zu wissen.
Oder man kauft sich so ein paar alte Basis-Stationen und macht so lange Re-Engineering, bis man weiß, wie man die Dinger in Place irgendwie tunen kann. Und dann kommt das Software-Update halt nicht von Nokia, sondern vielleicht auch wirklich aus der Open-Source-Gemeinde. Wer weiß.
Klar, unbedingt. Auf jeden Fall ein Weg. Und selbst wenn man nicht so weit gehen will, dann zumindest mal ein paar alte Basis-Stationen kaufen, die Sicherheitslücken heraus zu reverse-ingenieren und öffentlichkeitswirksam zu zeigen, wie man mal den ganzen Land vom Netz genommen hätte. Wäre man denn böse genug? Auch das würde, denke ich, einen Denkanstoß geben. Also die Community kann hier viel tun. Nicht nur als passiver Kunde, sondern als aktiver Contributor zumindest zur Selektionsstufe der Evolution.
Okay, Community, ich hoffe, ihr habt zugehört. Ihr wisst ja jetzt, was zu tun ist.
Bitte nur zu Hause probieren.
Genau. Die Links zu all dem finden sich wie immer in den Show-Notes. Und ich sage vielen Dank, Karsten. Das war ein sehr ergiebiges Gespräch, was auch alle anderen Sendungen hier zu GSM und Telefonie wunderbar ergänzt hat. Sicherlich nicht das letzte. Ich denke mal, mit Harald muss ich auch noch mal ein Wörtchen reden hier. Mit seinen Bassband-Experimenten. Ja, aber bis dahin bleibt mir erst mal nur wieder Tschüss zu sagen. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank auch wie immer für eure Unterstützung dieses Programms. Ich hoffe, ich höre euch bald wieder beim nächsten Mal wenn es heißt Chaosradio Express.